good morning hi budlings this sounds like halo halo music you should have heard it at
the start it was like what what right hold on let me meet myself we are I think about
this way um don't be distracted by the fact my heart rate is already in triple digits
and I'm just sitting butting up the game and talking that's normal for me please don't wear
fucking no the chunz the chunz what's going on all right hi mama hi reflynn oh hi y'all
good morning good evening good afternoon how are you holding up reflynn did you get big long
sleep yeah did you need to wake up and do a big stretch like yeah big stretch when you woke up this
morning okay now don't look at my heart rate if you look bottom left that is my heart rate I got
it to work yes I am very high heart rate most of the time um this is very natural for me so please
don't worry I am a half breed of hamster apparently um you got some sleep but it was hard oh no is it
difficult I see I've not ate but I've got a cup of tea um so I'm just having a big cup of tea
unfortunately I woke up late uh do you want to know what the update is with the script writers
obviously I added fuck all yesterday after stream because um apparently there's like 57
applications for the script writers so it's about to be a battle fucking royale I'm just gonna have
us all the script writers join me in a fortnite game and whoever's top of the lobby uh whoever's
one two three gets picked okay so we're gonna jump in fortnite together um but yes that's my job after
subnautica eh Louis thank you for becoming a member please do tell me if the volume uh option
right first let's put subtitles on whatever graphic no subtitles oh it's already on oh well
um right this game is called subnautica most vtubers punish themselves by playing it because
they have a fear of the ocean um I don't know about you but I know how to swim so I'm not really
scared of the ocean like maybe if a wall of jellyfish I was up against and they all stung me on the
way past like yeah oh it's that 60 up oh well guess who gets to go through them because I was the
previous script writer so yeah uh fortnite game with you I'm gonna play now but no I'll
let it fortnite battle pass I do apologize I did only wake up um start a new game well
first impressions subnautica so far look at the water physics on the main menu we're looking good
to boys we're looking fucking fabulous oh um uh glaceon samus samus oh neat you're playing the game
of love hope you don't mind that best nah this don't bother me none uh some people get really
bothered about it hmm you were the previous I can't believe you were the giggle stick fan
fuck I'm not the giggle stick fan the unfortunately uh they were fired uh they're no longer
part of the script um strone is not the water that's the scary part right do you want
spoil no don't spoil it until I come across it or if I go what am I doing right survival crashland
on a dangerous alien planet scavenge resources manage hunger and food to survive right okay freedom
like survival but no hunger or thirst will we be cheeky and do freedom because you know I'm
Scottish like I didn't care if you can hear from the accent sometimes it's a bit confusing hearing
a voice like that freedom seems like I don't have to get frustrated managing killing fish and eating
them as soon as what I'm going to be doing uh you'll be fine with the water food is it fine I
don't even hear the accent anymore hardcore I'm not playing hardcore zero oxygen hilarious what I
just have to fucking get survival right you know what I'll do a poll because every poll's a goal
start a poll strone please dot dot dot strone please freedom and then I'll put big Scotland
and then strone please survival like everyone else you dumb oh I can't spell I ran out of characters
to spell dumb but there you go strone please freedom in Scotland or survival like everyone else
you dumb you dumb but yeah subnautica apparently it's a very highly rated game um has it been on
my radar I'm not gonna tell fibbers um I would not be really playing this if it wasn't recommended to
me uh refunds were actually really interested in me playing it after debut and I was like huh
okay is it because of my wartime feature birth be honest are you profiling me
oh wow you guys are actually really split normally you're so on it right make sure you vote okay
register to vote by clicking subscribe to strone calls right now fuck that was good holy
shit I'm a real streamer did you hear that that came off the top of my head that came off the top
I'm good holy shit 51% really
hey she's a professional streamer there's a one song in the game that's really good for audio
it's very specific she's a really guys it's difficult she'll reach quit real stop real right okay
I guess we're going Scotland today we're going Scotland no more stalling wait what I mean one
by a fucking bot here one by a bot here see in Scotland we say if something's really close it was
by a bot here because look down and see your bot here see how short that is that's so short
that's how close it was oh
oh what oh right okay
oh yeah you want me to have different roles and be buckets huh you want me to have different roles
I can do anything you want be anything you want I can be a gas station manager
what the fuck I thought this was a game about the ocean
all right I remember this in the wee trailers this is like my wee room is it not
oh holy shit oh we're alive
oh fuck
jump scare what the fuck is that my eye I have glass in my eye no
oh yep
holy shit I'm gonna extinguish the fuck out of you oh I'm on fire hold on I'm on fire first
am I good
are we what kind of entrance to the good morning game to you too
booting in emergency mode altera okay
I was born like that it's fine thank you fenty and one for becoming a member
in emergency mode with one to keep you alive on an alien world please refer to the data bank
for detailed survival advice good luck good luck
you've suffered minor head trauma this is considered an optimal outcome
okay see uh I'm gonna drink my tea
even the game knows I only have one brain cell available true and real
at least you don't start in prison is that a skyrim reference are you todd howard look you've
already got enough stales on skyrim okay there's already enough to fit additions that have came
out there's already enough platforms that's came out on you've won todd howard you've won okay
it just works
mm what matters is we haven't lost their memories ah yes the memories of this game
yeah thank you again nb buckets for the tip I don't I don't think it's like me
instead of playing subnautica you should buy the 77th copy of skyrim right you're done hold on
I'm almost finished my tea
I played oblivion once and I did a big jump that I shouldn't have been able to go
just skip an entire section of this castle there's just brute force in the game right um
okay so my health is 71 my oxygen's 42
beacon manager blueprints oh my god right I'm not gonna look at the blueprints because I think
it's cheesing one two three for the corresponding slots what did you just call me let's get some oxygen
okay
I mean at least we survived
yes
we were the only one that survived there's not one other pod out in this option in this ocean
yeah
here down a wisdom tooth and the dentist was not gentle oh
I'm sorry to hear the organ did you not get the injection when I got my wisdom teeth removed the
injected right there's something over there so let's go to it oh did you see the way I
flopped into the water that was like a fucking belly flop right okay I'm getting resources
that was so good right I don't think I need any more acid mushrooms of the
yeah let's get some more you can I grab the fish no way I could just grab the hello mr fishy oh he
looks so cute all right what was that thing over here I don't know oh what are they lost oh shit
oh no I can see where my home pod is okay this thing it was like something over here
oh it's my it's the shadow of my boss something's making noises oh it's dolphins hello dolphin
you'll never guess look I have oh the fish stayed alive I guess wait he's got something in his mouth
whoa are you serious back the fuck off me bitch get off me I'm a cream on you how do I defeat it
he's fucking garden it right cute vein is this like the one came rough
oh egg could be thank you the thing right okay I need some sort of weapon inventory full oh
oh what's this a creature's egg uh if I grab that am I getting chased by the mum
okay let's imp tear
okay let's get oh no you need a knife mommy we can't hear brian is brian broken
what do you mean you can't hear brian
you don't hear this
oh in the words of jeremy farson still could be worse
oh my god my inventory is all asses
uh nutrient block a flare I'm not sure what I'm gonna get done with that
not oh my oh no it's not infinite infantry oh right okay hold oh no no that one uh head again
brian is super quiet for us chat anyway good luck with the game it's really fun with intense moments
okay good luck with the game personal expand resources basic materials
preproving craft craft I already have it silicone rubber
of course the first thing I'm making a game is a condom what the fuck
what hold on uh streamer streamer you're playing a game for the first time but you're not doing it
right yes that's because I'm playing it right
appropriate equipment using locally available materials okay
what are you making rubber for right we're done make the lubricant is essential in construction of
vehicles and power plants vehicles scanner survival knife I need rubber and titanium okay
did I have more rubber in here I think yeah me I please have this and then get rid of all these
fucking acid mushrooms that we don't need okay a fabricator there and then we needed
silicone rubber and then we need titanum salt deposit titanium oh titanium right I just made fins
so are the fins on me are these my fins are my rocking with the fins how do I know I've got fins on
my person metal salvage so that's what that hangs garden and irony that I need a knife to go and find
it uh right okay ready belly flop okay oh hello see you know how these are round that's how you
know they're friendly right because they're round right a writhing weed weed whoa is it friendly
I don't know that doesn't look too friendly to me hold on a minute I was gonna see
they look friend-shaped yeah they're circular if the animal is circular it's not aggressive
but I think he just farted on me do you mind excuse me sir sir right where's metal salvage
what are you doing can I touch you are you just gonna like fart on me again be honest touch
no they're they're not they just fart is that poison I want to kind of go in there far
honest point oh shit just take HP damage okay let me eat a snack bar um and I have a I have a
be um I have a bit metal so I can make a little uh thing in my bob right metal metal metal
metal yep right metal let's go titanium yes and then we can make a sword she sniffed the
brat I did and then a fire extinguisher we don't need pipes a chain of cape pipes can be used to
transport breathable air from a pump a floating air pump floating device that pumps air and pipes
actually what oh that's a bit advanced for me standard auto tank not right now uh let's take the knife
and then weapons were removed from standard survival blueprints for the massacre on a braxist
oh massacre that happened fire extinguisher mix co2
mix co2 no standard o2 tank compress assume this means I can breathe under water for longer right
thank you okay I get it now a scanner spectroscope scanner used to acquire technology blueprints
on data on living organisms okay okay let's start on off okay okay okay I get um I'm just clicking
right uh dive fix this use a repair tool okay let's see how I get repair to repair to
silicon cave sulfur and titanium right how do I acquire cave sulfur uh right let's go find a cave
and get some sulfur I guess uh let's get rid of these I'm gonna take these so I can redo my health
because my health isn't good right eye for inventory close enough no what did I heal here
inventory tab okay please use this thank you and then well I guess I don't need food
so put it all away if we're gonna go in an adventure let's make it count sorry I keep
pressing escape to get out of the menu but it's not putting me in a menu oh it's night time hmm
what do I need again cave sulfur do I need a light bulb
uh right right cave sulfur five is cave sulfur I'd be fucking hell I can't see
shake can you see anything do I need a light do I need to go fabricate a light I think I do
I can't see anything
a light bulb yeah literally I mean it's five o'clock it's basically night time
cut the creeper vein with the knife oh okay I can swing my sword sword you can
you definitely need a light soon okay I'm gonna get jump scared by something piece of ghost
ooh what's that oh you're so pretty oh you're a hover fish you're cute okay
what a pretty game why are we pretty pretty good all right oh break lame stone oh is this my cave
sulfur something's squeaking in the background oh it's just straight up titanium in here I'll take it
hmm in survival you can eat kelp oh my god they make you turn vegetarian their propaganda
has gone too far sorry right cave sulfur let's get one big breath of air and let's go in
hello is there any cave sulfur oh yeah oh yeah piss what are you oh yeah piss what are you
whoa no I didn't like you what do you mean a fucking thing are you aggressive I'll get back
you call that a knife I've got a knife fucking quartz sure I'll take quartz oh it's like a good
but did I get what I needed I don't think so
but something is clicking in the war I don't like it
hmm right did I get my cave sulfur I don't think I did I need my repair tool is this on fire
no it's just smoking right I'll keep smoking until I do it right we acquired fiber mesh
strong natural fiber and it's comfy oh we're getting a new fit fit check fit check
what did I acid mushroom and copper or make a battery battery oh I only got one quartz
so that wasn't enough I need a salt deposit okay we can
increase the local radiation levels trend is consistent for damage to the aurora's drive
core sustained during planet four uh-huh
fuck I have like too much shit um hmm
as much as I enjoy my whole of like all this can we not do that I'm like so feel right now
yeah architect rows are winning because I'm so did just drop it can I just drop it in here
can I not just drop it um how's the water dude uh that's what she said I'm so sorry
uh you can only drop things in the water that feels targeted against sorry I keep pressing escape
because I keep thinking I'm in a menu but I'm not in a menace
you could get rid of the acid mushrooms are pretty easy right what so if I press it now
I can drop it out no it has to be in the water well excuse me princess drop drop drop drop
can I just drop it all under the thing
okay right cave sulfur I'm coming for you cave sulfur I'm coming cave sulfur
um come come for the cave come for the cave I come for the cave I need a cave I need to
sign down right so I went life size so never go right size okay so we're just under 360
we've already been here let's go get some air and then go back down again stuff doesn't despawn
okay let's go okay cave sulfur yellow cavern secret cavern secret cavern I'm gonna grab the
quartz because it makes something that I don't know yeah what is this copper is an essential
component of all powered equipment okay your probability of survival has just increased to
unlikely but flaws detecting sulfur deposits in the local cave systems sulfur is an essential
yes I need sulfur so I'm trying to maintain the oxygen bar as well where's the sulfur a common
complication for cave divers is massive orientation yes yes so the based wiring
kits are an essential component of many habitat modules okay okay no that's fine that's fine right
we'll get some oxygen and we'll go back in here they are are they playing with the mail
give me that you bitch give me a little stop playing with the mail you don't need it the way I do
okay right if you're gonna go in that cave that's literally where I'm trying to go bro
or is it a dolphin that looks rather friendly honestly right did I pick up sulfur yet
maybe making noises behind me we creepy thing you
wait did I not get oxygen how am I already out there have I been mucking about
please tell me I picked up sulfur in this cavern oh yeah
right that's a lot seriously that's a lot
where's my home pod it's over here and before I dry already you didn't get max oxygen
ah it doesn't even go right away okay okay okay okay let him get up let him get up I love the
little fishies they're so cute whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what was that
what was that what was that what was that what was that what was that what was that what was that
talk about the AI being locked on to you are you serious
you just go back doing in that water sun I'm no bother in you you're no bother in me
fuck off this is my metal now you eat twat honestly
did you just see that right titanium they won the metal back honestly they're just silly
little guy did they kill me
right copper wire a wiring kit but what do I need to make this repair till cave sulfur I never
picked that up but she said it was in there Ken what Athena this is what I think about you Hen
standard or two if I make another one is it gonna double up my oxygen
if you leave them alone they'll leave you alone okay they bite okay
no feed the stalker and a fish and it'll become your friend and find metal for you I wish
I wish thank you the beauty lord I wish
a nihongo horny thank you for the tip as well is Brian still quiet or did I make him loud enough for you
no no just upgraded ones okay okay okay okay so I still need I still need cave sulfur a waterproof locker
Brian's okay still quiet as a mouse oh he's like super loud for me I'll do one more I'll do one more test
mama Brian is super quiet for us chat anyway good luck with the game it's really fun with
intense moments you hear this that's fine okay okay okay okay right oxygen tank I don't have any
gloves on I don't have microchips I don't have goggles and I don't have an outfit oh yeah put me
in a speedo I get to go in a speedo oh real I get to be aerodynamic I'm gonna show these I'm just
gonna drop all this fish I get to be aerodynamic outside right let's get rid of the fucking supplies
like you see these random supplies that I then you need right now to be holding on I'm just gonna
get rid of them okay uh I keep randomly have lead on my person glass
right and then we're gonna drop all this fish because I need it right so climb up the ladder
are you still out here harassing me no good right so they're over there
chillin is that stationary or is that something floating on the river and they're supposed to
be in the way I'm not really going this way belly flop right let's drop drop drop drop drop
all the fucking mushrooms going mental there all right we're not really going this way right
cave so I'm on the road again I don't know what the fire extinguishers supposed to do under the water
oh wow do you think this is where I'm supposed to scavenge metal you know
considering it was the start of the game and it's right here hmm a grav trap fragment can I go in here
yeah
tumor picks the most inefficient way to play the game
say it so well something's foreign that's a fissure an underwater fissure oh it's sorry sorry
I need the tank to fill up is that gonna blow me out or am I gonna die that blow me to the surface
oh right sorry it's lava it's lava don't get too excited don't get too excited it's
fucking lava refling okay don't be silly don't do what I do okay don't don't follow my lead I have
terrible leads there's a little red fish drop sulfur right we're going on a killing spree
hold on we're going back send me back send me back
the red fish or what I'm stabbing not you
there's whales in this game
whoa it goes deep
something's like a whale over here wait I want to explore I need oxygen to go further
oh wait hold on I need to go deep oh hello mr whale I hear you you sound close
wow what are you you have plankton on your back would you like me to scratch off
welcome to strunny's ASMR plankton removal service oh bestie see let me get rid of this plankton
you're like at a barb whoa I can go through them is this your baby yeah this is your little baby
break barnacle yeah see I'm removing the barnacle where is it break it watch out
oh I've got a copper ore for that
hello I bet you were one of those kids that stuck their hand in the fire to learn it was hot
uh actually get your facts right I was the kid that stared at the sun to see if it would
make me go blind so yeah and that's the truth fuck you I did hello
uh thank you crazy jesse for the tip and thank you basically with Oregon thank you for the extended
membership future patreon script strunny finds reeflings and subnaut con brings us aboard to
extract our precious resources whether we like it or not this just sounds like our word with
extra steps suggests this biome supports extensive biodiversity yeah you're not kidding the number
of small cave networks you are not yep I'd say this is fucking advanced I too is right one more big
pump of oxygen and we're off let's see what's down here okay the little red guys we need to get some
sulfur out of them we're just gonna gently treat sulfur out of their bodies okay but we love
yes but why not whoa it's purple hello oh that's not good hello can you fart sulfur
fuck I can't get it come here fuck I need your sulfur are you dead
did you just make me kill this poor thing
ow is that not what we're supposed to kill pentane one thank you for the three months membership
you can actually find an egg and hatch a cuttlefish to be your pet real I'd believe it
oxygen oxygen yes um
Scott bugs don't who has sulfur wrong fish oh my gosh
that's how you guys I'm colorblind no I'm not I'm fucking great let me go back
oh gosh are you serious the pod is like 300 meters that way I feel like we're better just going
no right right right hold on hold on we'll go to the pod and we'll go back into that cavern
because I know where it is the red one the red was that not red am I going mental was that not red
schizophrenia okay we'll swim back to the pod and then we'll go in that cavern because I know
where that actual cavern is where that sulfide is that's what he said sodium chloride no it's not
metal scraps I'm yum him this red fish or is that the one that I just killed and I'm going for his
brother no metal stuff whoa that's clicking back off I got a noise hear me I'm not I'm not afraid
anymore where this wait hold on let me get oxygen I may be discovering here red fish that blows up
you didn't but we figured because you kept saying Amy is ginger you definitely
Amy is a yin yo I don't know how anyone sees it whoa what the fuck back up
I am one HP in a dream uh I mean
that that was what I need to go heal up no I don't have medical supplies
um but I got sulfur sulfur what was I supposed to do that thing kamikaze enemy
okay look hello I have made it I would like to make one I don't know are you
careful mama some of these fish have bigger knives underscore mama thank you stash power yes
I think they do I don't think they do right I got cave sulfur I just need a rubber silicone
and titanium well good thing I'm can you close that please oh see what unstuck there's a button
to be unstuck right what was it titanium silicone rubber a bit titanium bob dronko
and we've got the repair kit right right we did it we have the fabric here power use repair tool
oh yeah oh yeah it like gravitate such shit fuck use the force
I put secondary systems online uh-huh running full environment diagnostic and
outputting results to data bank okay okay what are you what do you do
uh let me heal up
right secondary systems online outgoing radio comms offline incoming online floating device
deployed hull integrity okay environment uncharted ocean planet for five four six
bravo oxygen nitrogen atmosphere lucky us uh waterborne bacteria levels high
okay now that this is a solar power
settlement does that imply I have to fix this right I fixed the route oh sorry
use the force what did I repair radio okay radio hello
so
infinite hours there's no one on the ship
huh curious is there no bed in here damn I'm just never allowed to sleep again
escape exit pod from the bottom
are you you can get in and out from the bottom you'll never guess what I just done
you well you're gonna shit yourself when you figured out what I just figured out
crazy jesse thank you for the tip you are gonna shit yourself
right can you please put the knife on considering it's night time right
on the road
perfect timing no the pre-recorded allegations you fucked up the time and you were supposed
to do it five five seconds later okay earlier sorry you're gonna squid yourself
we have a lot of analysis okay it seems like there was a big ditch over there wait hold on
hold on hold on hold on let's check out what the other upgrades are before we start getting all
excited that I've done something good because I'm not sure I have yet right first things first
silver or glass titanium uh-huh do I have a silver ore I see let go silver this is
silver right we don't appear to have silver that's okay though 99,999 hours is 4,166 days
or 11 and a half years it's a bit of a way in that it's a bit they're taking the piss I think
we need to run a bit more you know a bit more proficient what I need two glasses how do I make
glass thank you Grimby feel our fuck um for the uh what I need for glass did I not just make glass
glass quartz cool thank you crazy J sorry I'll do better next thing yeah your your pay's getting
docked for that just what you should know right I need one more glass which is quartz which sorry
it's very confusing that the escape button isn't it's like not entering me in a menu
when you play games that are all menus it's very like huh okay another bit of glass and then we
have the updated oxygen tank huh what hold on hold on hold on I only need titanium hold on hold on
hold on hold on give mommy a second to think I need a moment to think hmm hmm okay okay and no
come on come on uh uh a wiring kit a wiring kit every breather conserves oxygen when diving
deeper absorbs the recycle wait have I fucked up oh there's my flashlight here is my flashlight
here is my stuff when you tip me over I will shout oh you can't uh no that's cold I need
copper right I have copper on my persons I have that for the acid and then I need glass again
which I'm I've already forgotten how to make
you can keep spare tanks in your infantry
why does it not look like my oxygen's going up am I going mental
right I need glass
and then what else did I need
I need
degradation
you're stressing me out hen hen you're stressing me out you need to stop partly
viewing right now all right I'm off to get some fucking you're stressing me out hen
right let me grab these right up we go
stressing me out for any reason degradation of the hall what the fuck happens with the
whole day gradates right battery right and give me that flashlight
okay give me the flashlight
why would you use extra tank through the fun
I just don't okay so now have a mean tool tool
please tell me I'm allowed a bigger knife than this right right
habitat builder well fabricate I'm no fucking fuss for that
Pathfinder 2 the poise holographic Pathfinder discus used to map a way back out of caverns
or hard to navigate spaces max 20 disks right well I'm not going back for cave sulfur that little
thing fucked me up that thing had me in a death grip you know that kangaroo video
where it's like holding the dog and then the guy comes on and punches the kangaroo in the face
to get the dog back that fish and the dog in that situation that can't I'm in a chokehold by those
fish right I don't even care what the photon pumps are a rebreather a wiring kit right okay
what's what's this a wiring kit the fuck is a wiring kit okay you're all asking for a wiring
kit but I'll have it available unless I'm like scanning over it w what was that oh a power
cell two batteries right okay if you had one battery two batteries and a rubber silicone right
right let it go and then I've got copper and that so I can meet and then
you can't craft using a crypt items you have two tanks your upgraded one isn't equipped
what the fuck why would it bro let go oh of course when I press escape that's how you're
supposed to get that one right I have two I have two tanks okay no press tab here okay
be caught in that it's her right to that okay
okay stop pressing escape I may not deferred hour please stop pressing escape okay uh right
battery when you do battery tragedy when you go
right let's grab a fucking few you bams right how many is that one two three four five right
one more one more round up round up round up and then we can go explore because I've been trying to
do these upgrades instead this game was this game's literally just upgrade similar oh I can't
believe it I can't believe if you boil down games I'm right and then I want a power cell I don't
know why I want it just give me a whoa what the fuck am I supposed to do with that where am I supposed
to put it a computer chip
oh a wiring kit is too silver oh do I have that
no I don't right two silvers are mission objective okay let's just fucking throw some shite in here
right I have one silver but we're gonna leave it in here in case I die I assume I get to keep my
inventory right all right all right fucking put no put that shite there right and then
let's just drop the mushrooms right we need silver am I and I'll drop that out in the inventory
Denny is that loading free med kits
inventory try making a scanner for upgrade simulator point oh
upgrade simulator is it because I'm low IQ be honest be honest with me is it because
you can see how my brain works for the first time when I'm playing a game like this
be honest what what do you thank you the beat about yes it's free med kit okay infinite health
let's go give me kindly thank you I've already forgotten what I'm supposed to be doing silver
surely I need silver right I'm off to the cave for silver I've already forgotten which direction
yeah I give it this way yeah
so how about we take a little detour and go this way then I need silver right so these are where
the farty boys are and the road again
so those guys aren't nice they're they're fake they're fake they're not nice
but I have a lot of them you can find it with a scanner mommy uh okay maybe I should
what are you hello pick up a floater what is it oh my god
what is it
what is it sorry that's the only thing that came to mind I'm so sorry that was the only
thing that came to mind what even is it what even is it there's some metal
on the road what was that silver
can I just pick up silver salt
why would it make such a noise why would it make such a noise
why would it do that oh my god my arms are tense are you serious
why would it make that noise oh I just heard my arm doing that I just tensed up my right arm
so much holy fuck oh there's like a big cave under here stop in my ear excuse me sorry one
it's not even five o'clock in the morning please relax no please don't do that again
don't do that again you understand where it stopped putting my knife away I need to
I don't know are you gonna be right now hi hi joining good luck thank you puk puk thank you
for the extended membership as well two months oh my god her baby's growing so well I'm so proud
of her baby thank you for feeding me whilst I'm pregnant with your child it's just a texture thing
oh my god texture death texture death dev team unplayable wow are they coming for me
they're nobby right I'm getting salt I'm getting salty what are you are you something
a brain coral fucking let me harvest that resource I'm a harvest of inventory school
right let's drop these things wow oh it's me pushing against my own texture
okay let's get right I see Seamoth fragment
I see both any Seamoth fragment fans I'm I too I'm a fan of the Seamoth fragment I don't know
about you but just where the fuck is that okay 200 take note of that oh shit
oh man oh no this can't be no piss off I'm coming for you no no no no no to complete this game
to complete this game you're just cheating because you have a long mouth get back get back you beast
no I'm not trying to harvest kelp get back you beast get back I say
you're putting me off my flow to get back to my wee hoos
does this guy ever sleep with that I guess I just don't need sleep
fellow beast
like they're first to us this Seamoth is so good what is it right uh did I even I did not get
anything I caught a brain coral sample I assume I can do something with this
all right we need one of these
we need
cyber mesh yeah and then I need to make a scanner scan scan scan which is in this one scanner I need
a battery did I not just fucking put like a billion batteries today so give me that back
are you serious
only guys she mass I'm not gonna make it right go and get some fucking acid
they'd be screaming I'm out here you need I'm making batteries right and then I'm making a scanner
and then the game's gonna tell me where I go to get the more items that I need okay I can do that
I can do that right I need battery
we want this give me this
shimmy shimmy yeah shimmy yeah shimmy yeah
drank swalla la la drank
ooh
this scanner can be used to synthesize blueprints
I'm on my hand replin
searching I'm search searching for what
oh you like that action
right no what would I do with it did I put something into it
okay is that my five and five entries
entries gazillionaire thank you for the 20 gifted memberships go back to the sea moth fragment you
just found why yes I know exactly where that is and I'm not at all disorientated
yes I think it's in this direction
thank you gazillionaire and congrats to those who caught it with your face please enjoy the emotes
what whoa what's making that not who's fucking blowing up
did you hear that sounds like bombs under the water also press F
self-scan complete vital signs normal continuing to monitor okay is this I'm here
thank you very much the most are coming soon to him ac
emmy and mercier having the first batch and then azure and sheebie and then reflins
what was it not here
actually real skills friend here was it not here
oh this this this is what I was supposed to remember
okay hello I would like to scan you oh
right can you scan a bit faster bro wait back off
which
what do I
strong actually mentioned this game has no auto save oh
say no more the game has no auto save and why would they do a silly thing like that
why would they do a silly thing like that right I'm not going to be intimidated anymore by these
stinky stinky things I'm going to go around okay I don't know what's past them but
I've had enough of them dictating their attack and other fishes
I'm the music don't worry I've got the music covered oh crap the sunlight's going
oh no is that bad to be
no no no you don't have to do that I promise you oh no don't do that that's not nice hold on
oh f*** not this is much better geez right stay away from them what's down here
hmm okay there's land that's good okay I've got my C M a n m a n m a n m a n m a n m a knees
okay
to an unknown environmental biome. Passing 100 meters. Oxygen efficiency decreased.
Ah.
Woo! Can I come in? Beep boop beep boop. Cut open to access. Cut open.
Oh. Right. Cut open. With what? With what would I cut this open? Hmm.
Strongly no. Wait. Good attempt. You'll need that for later.
You need a laser cutter. Oh. Okay.
Right. I'll try to remember this location. Need a new tool. How does one acquire a new tool in this game?
Other than, I guess, just going in.
I said there was a cavern entrance? I assume there's a new item in it that I need for my stonks.
Right. I'll see what's in here. I'm ready. I'm jumping them.
You think they're going to jump me? Can fart in someone else's face? It's not mine to do.
Scanning wreckages unlocks new recipes. Got a recipe. Seamoth fragment.
Oh! Don't do that! Fuck me!
What was that? Was he big or small? I've already lost him.
Is he for real? Comes and bites me and then fucks off? Are you serious? Peat off.
Yeah, I'd believe that.
Whoa! Whoa!
Oh, that's too deep for me. I need upgrades. I need upgrades. That's too deep.
That's too deep. I can't even survive that. I don't have enough oxygen. I need, like, the bare oxygen thing.
The data lady's funny. It is a cool cave, though. I like the purple. It's very pleasant on the eyes.
Okay, right. Stay here.
That was fucking terrifying. I thought that was an evil whale, but the whale isn't evil. The whale is nice. I like the whale. Hi, Mr. Whale.
Why is the music doing that? Does it need to do that? Doesn't it be so dramatic, honestly?
Hello, welcome to my ASMR parlor.
I can scan him? Sure, let's scan him.
A reef? It's called Reefback!
Wait, did I not finish the scans?
A rogue...
Rogue cradle.
What? Press Tab to view.
A complex cave-dwelling floor. The bright yellow core.
Right, why is the music all intense, though? Am I under attack? I feel like I'm safe with the whales, okay?
I'm just chilling with the whales. Why is the music all intense?
Is that how we look when you grow up? Yay, some nice and big flames.
I guess I'm actually just gonna try and get further away from the pod.
Are they just a texture? Okay.
Surely there'll be something to come across.
That music's too intense for me, though. I'm a bit of a baby.
A bit too intense, to be honest. A bit too intense.
Oh yeah, you like that? Yeah, I'm gonna scan you so hard. Scanning all over you.
Oh wait, we were just here. Dumbass. Dumbass!
Right, okay, I guess we're not here since we can't progress there.
That's just my death. Aging the scan. You know I will.
Right!
Okay.
Are you squiddin' me right now?
Stop force-feeding ya! No, you mean when I am force-feeding ya.
Thank you, Dainan, for two.
Ten pounds, Emine. Special gift voucher.
You is... Oh, he's gunnin'! There's another yin!
Is he gunnin' from me all the way up? No, he's going for another fish.
Right, hold on. Let me get oxygen and then we'll go straight down.
There's probably some item in here that we'd be wise to grab.
Come on.
Come on, lady. Come on, lady.
I'm trying.
It's so blinding. It's so tantalising. What is that?
Oh, it's pulsating.
Look, I didn't mean to get pulsed. It's throwing darts at me?
What kind of wildlife do they have on this planet that's so hostile? It's throwing darts?
Is that real?
Fuck your beach.
I'm fucking fighting a plant!
I'm fighting a plant!
Get out of here.
Fucking fighting a plant. What's this that I picked up?
A matured-er? There's no plant in the right conditions.
Okay, it's a shape. Hold on. Let's pop this one.
The scroll wheel is not very efficient, I said what I said.
Wait, I'm a fool.
I mean, I guess I can drop these.
Ooh, I'll pick that.
Ooh.
Okay.
If the whale can stop moaning in my ear, that'd be great.
That would be nice.
I don't mean to alarm you, but you're kind of moaning in my ear.
What?
I think your pot is going to explode in two hours.
This isn't my home for the rest of the game.
Same pose.
Thank you Grim by the other for the tap.
My pot, this isn't my home for the rest of the game.
Oh, is this the second batch of whales we've come across?
You can move items on your hotbar in your inventory.
The ship?
The ship blows up!
And how does one fix that?
Can I fix it blowing up?
Can I Pokemon go and fix the ship?
I'm skimming the water.
Fix the entire ship in two hours, you can't.
I'm going nuclear in two hours, you got me.
It's a story event.
Can I go up to the ship?
Wait, if I've got two hours, fuck it.
We swim into the ship after this.
Let me take my knife out.
Is this wreckage or is this scraps of metal?
It's metal salvage.
Will someone please think of the metal salvage?
Are you squinting me right now?
I don't know, are you squinting me right now?
Don't go to the ship.
Why not?
What do you mean?
I don't want to go to the ship.
You make me want to go more now.
Make me want to put my hands up and shit.
The ship needs to explode to progress the story.
What is going on?
I thought it was a wee game about being in the ocean.
What's going on here?
Right, I just need to drop everything I guess.
But these are so valuable, these resources.
Can I drop them and then they don't?
Please don't be spawned.
No, they don't.
Let's shake this over.
Oh my gosh, I'm so lightweight now.
I'm not worried for me.
Go to the ship there is our wordable reeflings there.
Oh yeah, I'm off.
You don't have to tell me twice.
Don't have to tell me twice.
I was saved.
Yeah, fuck you.
Right, save game.
Oh, game crash.
Please don't crash.
I want to take out.
My tools have power.
Brain power.
Fuel.
Let's get going.
Lairing in the ocean, honestly though.
First thing human does on a new planet,
where is it?
Oh, should I scan that?
I should probably scan that on the way.
Where is it?
I'm scanning.
Oh, look at that scan.
You like that?
Yeah, fuck you.
Show me that trash can schematic.
I want to know how you make that.
Oh, I was kidding.
Oh, fuck you.
Teach me how to make a vending machine.
I'm going to start with Japan when I rebuild.
Wait, what?
There's vending machine.
Wait, can I make a vending machine in my wee house?
It's a non-functioning sample.
I don't know what that means.
Stop.
Right, we're starting.
I will rebuild Japan.
Don't think I won't do it.
Scanning.
A fluid analyzer.
Fragment.
A graph trap.
Whoa, actually, those wee skinny guys are in here.
I'm going to get my knife back off.
You can make pretty neat faces.
Are these skinny guys in here?
Are these skinny wee arseholes in here?
Back off.
I've got a knife.
And you're not killing me.
That'll lose my inventory if I die.
Where are you?
You wee arseholes under here.
Fuck.
I think we actually might go away with that.
I don't know where they are, but yeah.
Okay, safe.
Safe.
Just somehow safe.
Very surprisingly.
See.
Ah, this is a ship.
Hello, Mr. Ship.
Oh, no.
Oh, I can't even go in it.
Fuck.
Are you serious?
Can I, like, go around and avoid the radiation?
Is it, like, a little bit of a safe place?
You can just drop stuff, Minecraft.
Come on.
See that skinny fish that's in here?
Can I go, like, around it, or is the radiation...
Like, I know I can't just put tinfoil around me
to protect myself from the radiation,
but, you know, a girl can try.
What's this?
Did I scan you?
Yeah, a little bit like I scanned you.
I will scan you now.
A Cyclops engine fragment.
It's a pretty...
pretty beast of a...
thing in the bober.
Can I go back behind the aureola?
Hello.
Hello, Mr. Ship.
Yeah, you look fucked up.
I don't even know how to climb a board.
I don't think I can.
It doesn't look textured to...
Ah, you fuck!
Oh, you fucker!
Fuck off!
Oh, my God!
Oh!
That's even worse!
I think I'd rather be in the water
so I don't have to see his fucking face
on top of this thing.
Oh, my God, I'm actually hiding behind my microphone.
I'm actually hiding behind my microphone right now.
Oh, my God!
Is that for real?
Am I supposed to 1v1 that?
Am I alive?
Is it still after me?
Bro, I'm staying next to the fucking safety of the pod.
Are you serious?
I'm sorry.
Please don't listen to me at load volumes.
Oh, my God!
What was that?
Am I genuinely supposed to 1v1?
You can kill it?
That fucking chance, are you joking?
With this fucking knife?
Look how small my knife is.
I feel emasculated now that I've seen that animal.
That creature in the deep.
I found a friend.
Some friend.
That was a reaper.
A hard-leave nor.
Why would I do that?
Oh, fuck you.
Oh, my God!
Right, so...
Does that mean that part of the map is inaccessible?
What does that mean?
What, does everyone get freaked out at that part?
Oh, Jesus.
Safety.
I'm just gonna curl up in a ball and fall asleep here after that.
Jesus.
You are definitely a siren.
Alright, I do, but what the fuck?
Non-functioning laboratory equipment.
Jesus, I need a moment.
Tiny spany, thank you.
Boy, thank you for the tip.
Tiny spany, thank you for the tip.
Michichonky bird.
Oh, I did not find a friend.
The Legend 27, one of us.
Thank you for the tip.
Did I get hurt?
I think it did get me.
Holy shit, yeah, it did.
Let me use that.
I don't...
What did I do?
What am I supposed to do next?
Are you squidding me right now?
Internet basil file, thank you for the extended membership.
You actually kinda did 1v1 it.
Normally you'd have been swallowed whole but your knife stabs.
Wait, he can swallow me?
Jesus.
What's this?
To attract light objects in small creatures.
Wait, something's making a noise.
You?
Play message?
He will eat you.
Oh, there's someone else here?
There's others?
I'm not alone?
Jesus.
Thank you stash power.
Yeah, okay, so scary.
Ali Viva, thank you for the three months.
You did well in that situation.
So I could have died right there and lost everything?
One fact, the reaper is the second biggest animal in the game, smile.
Over what?
That thing was massive.
Are you squidding me right now?
Reflings, what did mama say?
I think I just got permanent aid before I have extreme tonight.
How loud was my scream?
Can someone marshmallow a clip?
I don't know how loud my scream was.
Wait, where's that other one?
700 meters that way!
Oh, you're tapping on that.
It was very loud.
What's this, sorry.
Sorry deaflings.
Sorry little Reflings.
Right, I guess we're gonna go here.
Belly flop.
We're gonna avoid these guys though.
Oh god, they're all the way out there.
Go back into your little veins.
Loud enough to pop my ears.
I heard you from the other room.
Do you want us to hold your hands?
Are they coming for me?
Yeah, go for the wee flashlight.
Bring that one.
Okay, life pod three.
It's the fourth biggest animal?
There you go.
Thank you deafling and thank you Christophels and for the toast.
Right, let's get to it.
We're gonna see if there's other humans.
Hello, Farky Boy.
I know the fact that Baby Pink is online.
She may or may not be streaming entirely.
On the road again.
Wrong mindset.
Survive and explore, not dominate.
I can rather dominate you.
This is scary.
Can I stand on this?
You just hear my flip-flops going like
wank, wank, wank, wank, wank, wank.
And then back into the water.
Told you it's a horror game.
It's like, during the day, it's actually really pretty.
It's like, it's almost Pandora-esque.
You know what I mean?
Kind of like giving avatars at night when it's all pretty.
Oh, I'm fucking got PTSD going through fucking vines.
Right, that horrible thing's over there, so it's not here.
It's not here.
I'm safe.
I'm just gonna go around.
It's Spain.
Okay, I'm just playing it safe.
Can I scan this?
Delicious.
Whoa.
What?
Is it gonna blow up?
Five, two, one.
Three, two, one.
Is the Reaper dead now?
Is that how the Reaper dies?
From the shock wave?
Huh?
No, the Reaper is even more annoyed.
Well, he can come to me at any point now?
Don't say that. Don't say such things.
Don't think I won't scream again.
You better lower your volume.
Are those my friendly whales?
Hello.
Uh, Gutsh official.
Thank you for an extended membership.
You need to listen to its roars to avoid it.
Wait, here?
Right, I'm getting fucking...
I'm going to get sprannic now.
I'm losing it.
Oh my god, it's in the fucking vanes, please.
I can't handle vanes anymore.
Subbean, thank you for becoming a member as well.
I hope you enjoy them most.
I promise I'd sound more excited if I was a fucking terrible guy.
Okay, so those are the long-sleeved necks.
Oh, you wee shit, I fucking see you.
Oh, you wee fucking shit, I see you.
You're fucking hiding behind that rock.
Can I go inside this pod?
Shit, let me in. Let me in.
Let me in. Put me in.
Put me in.
Oh shit, it's broken into.
It has exploded?
What's this?
Abandoned PDA.
Wow.
Open data box.
Sure.
Come here.
Fuck, she died.
See you, you wee fucking shit.
Fuck off, bitch.
No, I'm not scared of you.
Actually, I'm terrified, but I'm not scared of you, go away.
I'm actually really scared to play this game.
I don't want to play anymore, I'm scared.
And it's about to be night time.
I don't want to be in the war at night.
I can end up falling.
I'm gonna make it.
The Reaper's about 55 meters in length.
Bro, I can't even handle 4 inches.
B.
55 meters. B.
Right, so I'm taking my light out.
No, that's my scanner. Take your light out.
Okay, it's not a wee bit less scary.
Just a wee bit though.
Just a wee bit less scary.
I am hovering on the surfer.
Target stomach folds real.
This?
I cannae tell what's supposed to be the music
and what's supposed to be the wee things giggling at me.
ee ee ee
All of here is like a little dolphin.
what are these noises can you tell them a bit jumpy now tea tea what if I was
jumpy can I why did they not make this multiplayer I just want you guys come
in and hold my hand through it do you know how cocky and confident I would be
against that reaper if I had a few reflins with me and be over that
reflin more like redid like we oh no not reflin sorry that we per redid you
know sleep there's a multiplayer mod the stalkers are probably gonna come for
me but that's okay god the fucking seaweed is extra see you sorry see you
honestly so dramatic for needy's and get me in the fucking thing give me a
minute oh right okay okay I'm okay right why am I back here I have no idea oh
radiation suit I need to lead in a fiber mesh and a copper wire and a wiring kit
no I did make a wiring kit did I not did I don't make a wiring kit
that's to make glad copper wire sorry sorry
okay held on a minute half binder to open the fuck off I don't need that no this
a wiring kit fuck I need silver ore I don't want to go any I don't want to go
any deeper wait did I need to send real much fun with the clip let's find out
let's find out if you did it here's a clip of you screaming okay right you're
gonna hear my scream valve try and lure it
I don't even know how I climb aboard I don't think I can it doesn't look texture
oh yeah fucker fuck oh my god
even water that's even water I'd rather be in the water so don't have to see his fucking face on top of this thing
okay I was a little bit pretty just a wee bit freaked out like it's just a wee bit
nothing nothing I can't eat right focus up what I need to I need lead is there
lead in this box I could have sworn I had a piece of lead I've won lead right I
need another bit of word and then a compass is a wiring kit and I've no
made a wiring kit because I need something for the wiring kit which is to
silver right and I don't have I only have one silver right so now what we
the fuck does that go back into caverns I think so right there seems to be a
lot of titanium so let's just get rid of this fish non-functional laboratory
equipment what does that mean Ken what it's non-functioning me because there's
any Ken what I'm doing right I need silver lead is found in the deeper
areas like the kelp forest where I'm gonna be a bottle wait am I dropping
this all over not too much but a little bit if it all just stays under there
right and then we're gonna drop the flares lead and okay refling
at my parents house we need to be quiet when we do it three seconds until in
extraction insert the screaming clip here that can be heard up to five miles
away wouldn't that be annoying if someone was screaming in your ear like
oh I'm gonna ink like wouldn't that be really annoying right where is the
cavern I'm not going near there I'm not going in that direction I do not care
right I think we'll go for the purple cavern which is this way right caverns
we need to go into caverns got it not if it's you it's underwater yes thank you
thank you tiny tiny for the fit at least your ASMR make was not on that thing
would have been blown out long ago long ago that thing would have been gone I
can already see the clip name of this brave first-time subnautica cuttlefish
player meets her first ah well freaking sound imminent I was fucking learning on
how to do the thingy so you know how man use short is like VTuber learns her
name is like butthole or whatever and you're not supposed to put your name
like it's not like strongy learns her name it's VTuber learns her name and
the algorithm likes that better like I'm not arguing against the algorithm but
if this gets turned into a clip then it's gonna be VTuber discovers Reaper in
subnautica for the first time like that kind of thing
blueprint acquired plate steel ingot okay like it's really interesting sorry I
could literally do a whole educational stream on trying on how to try and appease
the algorithm overlords I find it fascinating we personally I am very
fascinated on how to like try and get things to be successful or viral or
trying to trends and talk about trends and I have a drug education stream next
month I don't think I've done an education stream this month not that I
can recall people search VTuber more than any specified name yeah right
surely this cavern right there was a red fish that had a goat mate
right lovely big I'm sure nothing scary than this fucking cavern how can I know
hold a bloody flashlight and one I'll stop you're scaring me it's like loading
the textures in I'm gonna fucking drown so badly in here I don't think I'm
here I need resource though what is this goal I'll piss off I've just joined
myself eels yeah artificial I don't have what it takes
why is it taking three come on put me on a hundred fuck am I gonna drown I'm
gonna join wait why is it taking so much I'm less than a hundred relax brah
I'm less than a hundred relax stop taking so much wait it doesn't go back when
you go up
she's there's a lot of resources on aura well good for aura but I'm gonna go
near it unless I can go to the front of the ship can I go to the front of the
ship it takes three per day but I came up so that oxygen saved now shit Jesus
each o2 is one second of time oh it does take three at all good can I go to the
front of the Oreo I got the bends honestly the entire thing is radioactive
right I just need silver and lead where the fuck was that original cave I found
right fuck it I'm gonna go back and then replot my cave there's like a cave
somewhere in this general vicinity I'm scared of the fucking stalker things and
veins yeah then yeah him him I don't want to go toe-to-toe with him I don't
want to go fin-to-fin with him leave me alone no I'll leave you alone didn't I
tracked me be bum man this is like a hmm yeah this looks like resources
he's chasing me he is when they mail on and every one touched her bro right
right I never even touched her right is it respawn
can I do a little bitch how the fuck can you even fit no fuck you I've had enough
of you fucking bitch bitch yeah yeah fuck off poison bitch oh I'm sorry are
you dying I'm sorry to hear that don't care we'll bleed your poison elsewhere
you're fucking harassing me for long enough yeah that's right that's right
yeah fucking harvest your body for resources scan the fuck out of you oh
shit I'm not being beat up by the wildlife anymore price tab to view what
do you do a streamlined predatory encountered in the kelp forest and
weight of prey leaving the safety of the shallows to feed the stalker prey
lightly carved out its evolutionary niche as a sweet spot between feeding size
millions years ago and maybe oh shit I'm fucking drowning whilst I'm reading
about the lore of this fish no no allow me I'm gonna go schizophrenic oh my god
am I dead again stop I'm trying oh god that's so blinding I'm a gamer first
before I'm a survivalist okay okay there we go did I pick up anything I want
is there copper and titanium nah I need silver or lead is there no cavern there's
this like a one-way down the runway that air bubbles saved her are you what were
you silver right okay we've made progress we just need lead which is deeper I'm
sorry we phone you have to go deeper I said that I was crazy I don't know why
you're making such a remark like that way okay we got silver I just need lead
now I'm just checking through this bank this does seem a bit deeper I don't
remember did we go this way I'm looking around I see my wheels I don't see my
precious little haverns you're waiting the war but we hit the end too fast pop
pop pop pop is it weird that I almost find the wheels relaxing cuz I'm like
they're not gonna spawn a big enemy next to the nice cam wheels so I'm like the
wheels are saving me oh no I have been here this is where I needed that laser
thing and the yes the aura thing happened and apparently it didn't kill
the Reaper that's nearby ah nope not that one what we scan in it for oh pieces
what did you just give me titanium so scanning now harvest resources how I
still can't figure out how to get in here the 6th one
hmm I don't know how to figure out the laser beam does anyone want to spoil
how I achieve the laser beam for any particular reason just for a small
reason some of those boxes have tools in them scan them okay let's go back down
and scan them okay let's go
loud boy
if I was in a box and I was the laser I would be in this one and cargo GHD 3 no
not a scanning selfie demo and these haha I'm the cargo cuz I'm so valuable
he he I'll be really funny bacteria levels in the water performing a self-scan
is advised where you for real I get like infected self-scan complete vital
science normal detecting trace amounts of foreign bacteria we plan to monitor we
plan fucking zombies out here I'm about to turn into a fucking aquatic zombie you
have to mourn to make innumendos about refunds to find a little car honestly
yeah why am I so bad at finding it I'm like this right you go up rocks you're
gonna come back down a blueprints for a bioreactor I'm sure it's fine don't
worry about it not every disease means zombies I just like mmm zombie fish is
the only logical reason is it that box maybe it's that box like the further away
like that your skin will start bubbling wait so not only do I have to survive in
the game imagine if I had to deal with my health in my water right now as well
well I'd be fucking off on one I'd be gone so I'd be out but now I have to do
a zombie fucking virus no stop wait I've already been here dressed wait I've
been in this place before I'm sorry what I'm getting all mixed about what I have
and haven't scanned I see quartz don't be aggressive shit I see these they're
just glass though brah I'm looking I promise I'm looking I'm not trolling I
just can't find it deja vu I've been in this place before scanning all the mail
and I can't find the blueprints this fucking laser is not gonna come into my
inventory and I still have to make the thing hmm I can't find the box I'm
supposed to scan I scanned one thing there's nothing left for you in this
spot I have to scan it at another site you'll have to find it at a different
area but not in that area well that area there I need to go further out must I go
further how much further must I travel there's other wreckages that'll come
across okay I've got the anxiety playing this game a little bit shoulda taken a wee
bit of blocker with a felt belt thank you knee home good morning for the tip as
well I don't think I thank you by name or tiny spiny I'm sorry I've been really
is again dark soon you mean at night time there's more aggressive yin's like you
know more aggressive than normal at night is that what you're implying right
now is that the lure that you're dropping I don't want titanium I want lead and
silver and call me a magpie I want shiny and whiskers on kittens something on
men's these are a few of my favorite things but really I just want some fucking
way why is it going green why are you green now we flings are more aggressive
at night I don't think they get more aggressive I'm about to on why is it
green am I missing something I am a little butterfly we make the moves
push that college and you start right bucket we're harvesting this quote whoa
wait wait wait you really loud hold on it's not over it's not over until it's
over you fucking our school you need special equipment to harvest it yes
called my hands I'm grabbing it and taking it back with me fuck you are you
serious whoa this looks like there's nothing that lives here I'm getting
scared it's best to keep exploring new areas you haven't been to I'm getting
scared hold on maybe it's just more of a thing about oh oh oh I'm playing one
handed right now that's how scared I am to like a look around okay we're flash
banging the flash banging them I don't know are you squid me right now that's
fine I can deal with that that's fine oh sand boo we got hurt by a little sand
boo we came on thank you for the extended membership three months I see you
we ban what oh no it's just a wee fish it's just a wee fish right let's go get
some oxygen can I camp above the water until it becomes daylight again what
happens if you let me camp above the water so I didn't have to go in at night
time would you love me if I was scared and got to oh my god I'm actually getting
terrified now I wanted to be daylight like right fucking now don't really
want to move don't really want the AI to target me I'm just gonna stall okay
stalling I'm stalling should I say fuck I'll save I'm stalling I'm stalling I'm
checking my inventory I'm still full manager why ain't taking the data bank
stalling oh I'm just so interested in my inventory right now oh isn't that so
curious mmm it is what are you ultra strong synthetic construction
material
is but what does that even mean yeah I seem to be safe on the edge maybe edging
was the answer all along I'll wait until daylight and then I'll go in I get the
balls this is why I'm terrified of the ocean just a deep darkness full of God
knows what underscore mama underscore mama thank you for the tip I just want
to see a detail I'm not sure I've got the balls to fucking travel at night after
before so he was a bit he was a bit feisty after I've met him he's that
feisty mommy wasn't expecting him I was like oh I want to get on the ship and
then pull I'm like alright excuse yourself I've got a one-skirt
oh it's plankton plankton I was like why is me fibers coming in and out of my
range feels that home I'm getting shagged over here speak for yourself
speak for yourself my power levels oh shit am I wasting my torch I'm wasting
my torches is it daylight you know the thing is hauling ass if you can
visibly see how fast it's moving yeah where's the Sun we on fucking Tatooine
where's the wire well yeah why does he keep throwing me into the war come on
bring the Sun out where is it it's night yabam I'm waiting for the Sun the
way the planet has some wild cosmology once you build a base you can place a
bed and skip the night like Minecraft oh my god Minecraft is it coming I don't
know is it getting brighter or is that just copium I think it's just copium to
be honest I don't like see the horizon getting brighter pure raw copium this
perfect plan this place looks like the perfect planet to dump batteries
something just London I'm actually becoming schizophrenic for this game I
genuinely think stuff's moving about when it's not you see the way the like
the light is glistening through the war I thought that was a big long thing
circle and round me like a goddamn sneak that's what we want to see baby we
love sunlight up in this house right we're gonna explore and we just need it
to show up a little bit faster okay I can't wait to see your reaction to the
Cyclops voice oh the fish talk to me wait is this place just always green fuck
I think this place is just always green right let's go I can see something in the
distance it's rendered out let's take it easy we're let's skim the surface what
did they say let's trade the surface come on me fun let's trade the surface I'm
treading it I'm so fucking scared right now oh god it's my whale right no if my
whale's in that means that everyone's gonna be friendly nearby can I have my
whale please mr. whale can you guide me through the fucking depth I'm I'm
analyzing my eyeballs you probably can actually see more than me because I'm
being oh there's something down there fuck back fuck there's something down
there fuck it right we're gonna go get it and scan wherever the fucks down there
I see it fuck I actually scared oh my god this is why I don't play horror games
or anything about nature right we're gonna get oxygen and we're gonna go dive
straight down okay copium our whale is there which means there's no nearby
enemies copium go I'm going we're sending it we're going straight down
come on render distance okay there we go I see the outline I see the outline
please don't be a grass patch that I'm falling for right now that'd be really
lovely am I gonna get snipe wait what I got fucking snipe does this not wreckage
oh my god I'm gonna get snipe by something it's gonna come fucking flying
out of the war I'm gonna get snipe I'm not good
kind there's a good kind of stream sniping yes this is oh my god there's a
fucking other thing can I grab this thing fucking give me this give me it
right up the drone there's stuff for me to scan though hydroclone and acid it's
very bad for your skin okay nothing attacked me that went surprisingly well
so I wasted all that time waiting for night time for no reason
I think if I go down one more time I'll probably be able to scan something and
then I can get the laser tool make a note to come back here later yeah it's
probably too deep for your current gear you've not by going too deep with me
everything oh there seems to be something in the distance that's like it
looks like an older ship that's broken down hmm they're in the shallows right
okay let's go get a laser fragment and upgrade our gear like the waters actually
got a green hue to you know that I've just noticed that so I guess we are on a
section so this is like a genuine map though it's not just randomly and
generated like we're in the green abyss if you will and then there'll be like
other bits like the shallow veins as soon as you come out yeah it's not random
okay I'm glad that is not random I feel like if it was random that'd be less
fun I'm just gonna pretend there's absolutely nothing nibbling at my toes
right now I'm not even looking back actually I'm so confident I shan't be
attacked I'm heady I'm belaning I'm belaning for my little car all the
pieces of the same place okay
she's starting to gain that salaphobia is that the fear of the war you know what
I don't like the sensory swap from being on the surface to under because as soon
as you go under you hear all of this stuff just keep swimming some resources
are placed there may randomly but there is a defined map and major aspect the
tonic there thank you for the tip as well and that thank you for coming a
member see the music's all nice so assume I'm in a nice part of the map music's
all nice again so goes music's all nice life good happy days once the music's
all night I don't need more titanium I've got enough titanium to last me in
there travels sounds travel much better I know I don't want to escape nothing's
nibbling at my toes so I think I'm already at this part of the map right we
need to just upgrade our gear and then we can see about exploring that purple
cavern and that area we just found in the green sea I'm just gonna call that
place a green sea from now on
can I nibble your toes only if you call yourself brief on here it's for the
emergency really feel like you're in the deep ocean well they're bloody done a
good job of it because I'm getting fucking terrified it's a long time to see
how are you in here I've got another voice message this is every Quinn of
trading ships and Aurora do you read over no Aurora's fucking need the vacuum
these all terrorists ships they run low on engine grease and an SOS help they
don't think up Aurora I'm out on the far side of the system it's gonna take more
than a week to reach your position do you still need our assistance over I'll
try them again tomorrow so someone could have came respond can I even respond
that I have come my call outgoing comms are offline I can't respond there's
nothing I can do it just receive right right I need a wiring kit for a
rebreather I need to lead and I only got one of course that would be too easy
quartz quartz salt copper I've got a silver what is silver for mmm I'm not
supposed to know these off the top of my head like please be so for you a wiring
kit and fiber mesh can I make a wiring kit yes or no the answer at this point in
time is maybe silver okay I can make a wiring kit okay the first thing first
make a wiring kit and then with the wiring kit we will make it into I need a
fiber mesh to have a fiber mesh in here we're gonna make it into that rebreather
thing conserves oxygen when diving deeper up there yeah so this is it no
you'd rather the compass I don't have to lead for the suit wait what's better
compass or rebreather cuz we breathe I could breathe more just place compass
heading on the hud compass if you want help for fragments like it'll tell me
where lead is
not saying rebreather for sure we breather come sorry I just stopped seeing
the word compass and then I said come sorry please don't come do not come right
I've got the rebreather and then I need to put it on by dragging it oh no it's
on okay and then we're gonna go get some motherfucking lead right so we can
upgrade and lead is found where my darlings where is lead found and what
is oh right it's kind of a bit too close for my comfort but why are you on the
surface you are floating it must be I like to brown nodes near you have a
20% chance for lead say no more oh sorry I was embarrassing
360 there right brown no don't far don't far I'm just looking for stuff yeah
brown no for you acid mushroom brown lame stone close enough I guess no we need
like haven't yeah yeah yeah cavern cavern
did I pick up yet
they come out I do need more so what the fuck why are they so like crazy can I
not
what the fuck why are they so crazy I can't get we I'm too slow oh at least I
can get more of those and I'm even that lame scorn need titanium I got it I got
it I got it I got it I got it I got it I got it I got it okay so upgrade so
upgrade coming I got it I got it I got it I got it I got it they're like
self-destructing grunts from Halo do you like my pile of shit that's just
accumulating over time okay now we can upgrade this okay let's upgrade the suit
I need to fiber mesh and need like wait come here lead fiber mesh and then how
do I make fiber mesh how do I make fiber mesh
wait what was it fiber mesh I need it from Creepvine sample I think there's two
below actually excuse me a moment I think there's actually Creepvine sample
where's a Creepvine where is it there is look we'll just harvest it from here
and we can do it this smooth ones have lead remember that moment I'm I am
putting it in my mind right there they'll do it and then we'll have radiation
suit so we can't be hurt by the radiation anymore and then something else
mm-hmm gorgeous stunning put it on right put that in I know it can no longer be
harmed by radiation wait that means I'm going to the aurora
a better fucking no be does that mean I have to go to Aurora next to Reaper
why not did you know hear me script what why do you not want to go back here go
and then listen to this and tell me why I didn't want to go back tell me why I
didn't want to go back let's go let's go for the second screen while we're at it
while we're here let's go for the second screen tell me why I didn't want to go
back with my wee radiation suit mmm the loot the loot I'll show you what yeah
boot right so that means in order to complete the campaign how do I get more
storage actually kind of needs more storage I'm gonna lie golden hydrochloric
acid and Paula Nialine filtered war disinfected war I cooked bed you don't
even have a submachine I make submachine I make submachine a sea
great mobile vehicle bay two glass lead lubricant and titanium titanium right so
I can do titanium ingot and then I need a seed of the cluster and then what what
is that give me the metal the fucks room of peaceful steering I need like four
more one two three four as I miss clicked on something and then I need the eggs on
the vein
checklist sea glade and then a base and then a vehicle what I was gonna say this
game cost a lot of money let's just say that it was me a cheap one right
right make loop first and then me titanium
fucking hell and then what what was the fucking list of ingredients then two
glass and ledge
I have one glass how do I make glass again from court okay
well I'm just going new radio signal right make glass I can do that chat you can't save
or it's too late save save I'm saving thank you
yeah I take theory I wish to play this game
this is sunday again we just picked up a massive debris field at your location
I didn't know how bad how many of you I didn't know we're now enroute to your location
we're gonna bring you home sunday out
I need something else can I say the only time I parked a rig this big on a rock that small
was in VR and I blew it it's a bad option all right but so are all the others
they're not coming
open mate I don't have open mate outgoing radio communication offline
stronger you are making these 48 hours of no inking harder it's not even been 24 hours
yet and I am already struggling that's the whole point
thank you giving tips and crazy jfb thank you as well
and zik as well for the membership right so if I've got a reason I need to meet the I need lead
and lead is found in the b balls right is it night time I don't want to go in when it's
night time right fuck it no leave me alone hold on I'm gonna stall okay should I go get I'm gonna
can I stall and get a caller will you guys stay watch whilst I go get a caller
are you were you watch just watch yeah
don't didn't we need a vehicle be yeah okay I'm gonna get a caller I'll be a moment
and oh this game is horrifying oh no it's my heart rate monitor disconnect if I go to the fridge
I better not well anyway this is me standing up you can watch my heart rate go grab a cola why not
so
did it disconnect
I see my heart rate yeah that's how I'm gonna stand up
no don't give me money I was debating on getting a cheese spring or no and I was like no I won't get
a cheese spring I'll be here yeah when my when I stand up my heart rate goes up I don't know why
it just goes like when I'm like okay can you not do that thank you call car and abis are
sorry sorry sorry sorry of course not a blood flow will be like um yeah the blood was everywhere
else he he yeah the planet is be zoom in is there birds no that can't be right there can't be birds
they need to be able to land on stuff what is that supposed to be in the water and that's a texture error
I'm sorry I just didn't buy the fucking facility that was fucking there are birds there's fish birds
is that what they are they're just having a wee sail funny you mentioned that no those are birds
that could be like pots oh no blood men from flood born I don't think that is strange because it's
the moon's beautiful tonight
they really stick to the surface those ones
okay I've had my cola what I need to do right lead it's literally why is it whenever I scroll
wheel to the knife it never goes on it like ever right lead
so 360 ah close enough ah imagine if I popped my supply pod like um doing like that
I wouldn't put a pass right right wait till it's ovulation time again 48 hours will seem like a walk
in the park I'm afraid you've got a little bit of a wait for the next ovulation
right I found it in a cavern here so there must be more shallow caverns
I can grab it from
are they back no they're gone
are you smooth your limestone
no what are you
you
give me lead now
maybe a week will seem like a blink of time yeah
oh yeah some of these are on nine days and seven days and six laser
laser are you my laser
fuck
are you my laser beam
ooh you look smooth oh like lead hell yeah we need one more radiation detected good thing I'm
oh I need to breathe actually wait did I take damage from the radiation if I've got my suit on
that need even more
oh no no no no no you need a helmet too
fuck
it was a lot further away right like a lot further away
must have been
what have I got my inventory's getting a bit full I still need more lead now
what was that smooth
no he's fine a better view
yeah
support salt glass I got silver those are pretty rare
I don't think my suit's ready for this yeah
I need one more lead
you can remove the radiation if you go to the ship you wee bastard you sorry he's
wee tiny are you squiddin me right now cheeky thing coming at me like that
oh great mama please enlighten us does ovulation time mean you're less or more fertile I'm only
asking you because the internet told me nothing so um don't worry if you don't know about this
don't be embarrassed it's absolutely nothing to do with you it's just education um you a
woman me hi um I know scary uh I can only get pregnant for a window of like 48 hours in a month
and that's what um the ovulation cycle is so when I say I'm ovulating I literally am fertile
like you can put a baby in me that's what I mean okay
but for the rest of the month you're unable to get me pregnant like you you don't have to pull out
does that make sense that's how ovulation works um and humans wait you're a woman this whole time
I'm so sorry I had to find out like this forgive me forgive me right and then I need to scan one
more oh I see you are you coming at me no he's he's fighting something else couldn't do you think I
could sneak around is he AI locked on to me no he's fighting something else is that box though
I think it might have my laser in it I'm like a cat I just want my laser point now woman on
stream yes so everyone I'm tell you I'm like oh I'm ovulating that um what normally a side effect
of that is like increased lebedo increased submissiveness right hopefully he's gonna be
distracted and I can scan wherever I need oh it's not here of course it's not me
I'm like oh don't do that that scared me that noise scared me
it's the side effect yeah oh he's coming he's coming integrating new pda data and he's going
for something else oh no he's going for me oh I'm trapped it growls like a lion
ah I can't seem to faint oh fuck I'm full I mean I didn't really need titanium I have enough of it
at home don't need more of that metal salvage I can drop that that's again just titanium
that box or was that box we've already scanned it probably
yeah I think um ink has like a 5d living span inside the womb just because of the womb is optimized
to obviously hold the yes the
no why am I scanning it looks like I'm gonna be like geological data
is this it no what more do you want more greedy greedy pure greed
you want more scans of it how is that not enough I want inside that little pod thing
now this is pod racing
all right he's gonna oh you look like it I'ma take the L and get bitten by this guy
I'ma take the L and get bitten by him oh what's he missed
blue print is quiet oh wait hold on that looks like lead down there out on a minute oh it's like
lead are you lead please be loud oh oh dubs dubs all around dubs all around are you smooth
yes when they're smooth I'm getting it my brain cells they're growing my brain's getting wrinklier
there is a few good other bits there okay let's get the laser cutter and then we'll go into the
room which I've already forgotten the location of sandstone is laid I'm lame it only took me
two hours to grasp the basic mechanics of the game this cut off fish is the woven already
basically was thank you for the tip and the booty load get educated again so fast can I just
get to learn about all these cool things that's actually really cool I like that they had that
in James Cameron's avatar game it congrats every names james um and they had like encyclopedias
and I used to read them look oh my god what are the it's a floater are they attacking that
what's going on here you don't need to hold still I'm trying to scan you a floater
curious right we've achieved something I'm gonna be honest I've already forgot what we've achieved
I'll take it um a battery diamond oh I don't even know where to get diamond
where a battery I need a battery
um a battery a battery a battery a battery is two acid mushrooms right and how
fills my inventory they I'll go get we two acid mushrooms and I'll go get a battery
okay give me a minute I need to go get about a wee battery wee battery yeah one whole battery
for weapons rescue these mushrooms are gonna be the end of my life
uh yes I need diamond I'm not sure how to obtain diamond
did she make a vehicle way I have not diamonds are found at deep slate levels
gonna need a battery recharge or something diamond is even deeper is this not deep enough
I feel like this is more than adequate
ingredients unknown waterproof lock or small storage solution
uses artificial gravity no I'm not wasting my money I recommend finding the vehicle base
fragments why yes I would know where to go for that oh wait wasn't I not building something
wait I could have sworn I was building something this how'd I pin how'd I create it
but I've got all the ingredients for it
Sony you will need to build the sea more
in the vehicle bay
vehicle bay what's that mean yeah you need a vehicle with the vehicle
oh this oh shit
okay okay okay okay okay no no not all this lost right that just means that we need to be big boys
and ghettos and go explore love me some exploring I don't know about you love me some exploring I
do no really I do it doesn't terrify me at all right I guess we just drop this and that
oh wow that was like taking up so much inventory space I'll hold on to these things don't really
make them okay it's already become night time so one that's terrifying two don't do that
keep the rebreather wait what did I drop this
this the regular one
oh I don't need to put that helmet on when I'm going in radiation sites
mummies pull it in the ocean literally look at all this fish I've collected my resources
my human right well it was that way where all that shit was wasn't it
I want to go in again
use only the radiation when I'm in radiation okay that radiation area had like tons of stuff in it though
use more oxygen when you're lower than 100 the rebreather changes that to 200
up meet the sand shark mr sand shark can you fuck off I'm not in the mood
to get bitten off bum bum bum bum that is my fault sorry I don't know why I don't know why
I see a box there I've already investigated the box well someone please think about me
investigating the box I'm definitely not at the ship it was at the ship is where the
reaper spawns and reaper way back into mine swinging my pickaxe from side to side
starting investigating the box am I not allowed to investigate a box is that legal
is this some storage box no no let's search up right thing I'll go ask myself then
ooh blue hello where are you oh I don't really feel like plundering creatures eggs you know
you don't think of the bio diversity I'm in
in
I am soothing myself with that shit by the way so I should move for a bro
can I scan this please no scan no scan go after yourself okay
I seem to be severely locking um oh it's right behind me
please tell me the reapers in your bio
I'm out it was nice knowing you honestly fantastic game love it absolutely love it adore it really
adore the game no I do um fantastic I think it's well worth the money
well worth the money just well worth the money over here okay you can hear the
reapers don't say that are you serious oh don't are you serious can you hear it
stop are you serious
stop are you serious what was the noise stop I don't fucking see it oh yeah my
ass cheeks are so clenched right now I could create a fucking diamond oh my god
stop did you actually hear it are you trolling me
stop I'm not fucking with that I'm not fucking with that I'm not I'm not by that life
put on that rebreather right now fuck I'm still in the radiation zone
yes we could actually it was going off the entire time wait why was I ignoring it how can I tell the
difference battery's less than five percent love you oh you gotta go it's a worry you have to go
save fuck yeah go back to the pod quick wait why it just doesn't chase me all the way to the pod it
gives up don't say that what do you mean get back quick stop it doesn't chase me to the pod right
the EI wouldn't do that the the dev team wouldn't do that
yeah the reaper was behind you he said die die die before real fucking real
right I don't want to go that way anymore I want to go to the other site that I couldn't
scan that well because I was too busy drowning why are we here just to suffer how do I
how do I power my tools up
how do I power them up again
um
it's a solar power cell this
try crafting I see like this make new batteries or get charged in are you switching me right now
you know some of those whale calls you keep hearing yeah that's the reaper and the other fish
he's talking to his buddies to gang up on me I can't believe I'm being singled out like this
it's because I'm Scottish isn't it I can't believe that modern day fisheries of them
he heard it here folks he heard it here folks fucking racist against a cuttlefish man can you
um you have to charge the batteries
thank you stash power and anonymous
yeah actually I shouldn't do it together I should do right I can go to the green scene
now right because I have the rebreather all right that's how it works right
but we're just gonna enjoy our lovely day together right here
here sea glider equals three times wait hold on let's go inside right open up inventory sea
glider ingredients unknown I've not came across it when did I come across this then
vehicle upgrades I've never even got the vehicle in the first place to get the upgrade
elam enameled glass vortex torpedo now come on dev team what's going on here with a shape come on
let's no beat around the bush we all know what that is
well that's where the back door we get torpedo
oh
Cyclops engine I don't know are you should pay a visit to the dead zone what is is the dead zone
the one back there the green sea is that the same is the dead zone I repeat thank you the
bit lord for the tip um my heart rate looks fine so I think we can continue interior
install interior a bioreactor composes organic matter into electronic energy oh my god I want
a vending machine I'm gonna do a vending machine the dead zone bad I don't even know where it is
I'm gonna even discovered it like the abyssal nope it's far far out
yeah my heart rate's pretty relaxed right now it's because I'm talking to you stalling for the
freaking as soon as I go back out there I don't know what my highest heart rate's been so far
oh I should probably heal up with the med kit I do love a good free med kit every once in a while
actually really like that I think that this is a really good mechanic I see 10 out of 10
especially for gamers like me who are trash right we're gonna go to the green sea and the reason
for that is because there was a site that I never investigated properly a phastoroid
want to see my asteroid sorry thank you for the the membership please enjoy the most um
and thank you for the support and one three five damn you think I was about to buy something
that bitch oh who said that that's very nice how are you enjoying the game I actually
I'm gonna be I'm gonna tell you the truth I thought I was gonna hate this game I actually
really like it the only thing I'm struggling with is getting the balls to this stuff that's
what I'm struggling with like this looks like the green sea to me I'm gonna go get some water
war and then we'll go scan the stuff down there I thought I was gonna despise it but actually
didn't he oh no I've already been here no it's further out it's further out um
Shawnee the reapers the are you didn't no don't spoil us ahead I'm just gonna keep moving away
oh I think the green sea was over here right let's see what we're looking at we're gonna
ease you into horror get oh no I'm not a horror game player don't be like oh it's October Shawnee
is going to be playing tons of horror games because all you're gonna get is your ears freaking
blowing the fuck out okay I just start screaming I mean fuck my neighbors heard that scream at five
a.m. in the morning like what they're gonna be thinking I'm getting murdered
murder yes murdered not to be dramatic not to be dramatic but murder
no silent hill stream isn't silent hill that game no no it's resident evils that I have a
bone to pick with they give you a gun that can he kill folk I'm like no they're gonna give me a gun
if I can't you know oh my god what I said Squidward walking around my room right now
wait did I not just
this game has fucking eclipses I was like did I not just bloody wait for this to get bright
so I can explore don't be selfish scaring me like that
I just got freaking scared by an eclipse oh and that true thing oh me okay yes this was the
green sea if I'm not mistaken yes I had these is it stalagmites I never remember
stalagmites on the floor
hmm stalagmites stalagmites
you want me to play amnesia yeah fat fucking chance I never got past the water level
do you want do you want to know some really fun lore that's not fun it's actually embarrassing
well it's not embarrassing because every fucking everyone did it so I watched Pewdiepie when I was
younger and I watched him play amnesia and I was like I shit you know I must have been seven years
old and I recorded my webcam microphone I was very very young okay this is the green sea let's go
down and played amnesia for an hour on fraps or something like that obviously I was very fucking
young so I think I got all the viruses in the world with it um but like oh let me make sure my
rebreather's on that show there we'll scan everything
stalagmite hanging on the roof because they have to hold on tight
actually that's not a bad way to remember it right here we go let's get some data
let's get some data boys hello okay I grabbed that and then I piece the fuck out because I didn't
have this rebreather at the time but now I have a rebreather
modification station what are you I'm not even supposed to be of anything
oh supply for it what is it take item
I feel like I feel like that's tutorial stuff that I probably should have figured out a long
time ago a rebreather me when I want to run through with you a desk fuck yeah give me a desk I'm so
excited uh oh found a desk recipe oh my god please let me out I'm gonna fucking drown
must be something in one of these
I seem safe honestly I don't actually see any enemies here so I think the green sea is safe and
it's just uh it's so deep you should be so scared the green sea you don't need war because you're so
you're already wet real well is this easy mode no it's tutorial stuff for survival mode honestly
do you die on zero oxygen or die like take hp damage because I think I may have fucked up
did I fuck up holy shit how did I keep doing that I'm so emoji okay let's go in
uh you die one hp in a dream your vision starts there darkening and then you respond
you start down lose all my inventory
you swap the tank oh maybe I should pick up the tank because it means I'm gonna explore for
longer as well which would actually be really handy
I'm scanning scanning caution rogue robot you lose some of it well better not be the important
parts that I've been fucking going nuts trying to get maybe region ooh a torpedo
ooh
a thermal plan okay but these aren't anything that I need right there's been trolled
I think I'm just gonna trolled thermal plan I can only use that
oh
ooh cavern oh something in the bottom of the cavern can we do it I'm tempted I think we're
gonna try for it and see what happens can I load a last save if I die
I know don't go for it save before you go down I agreed can we do it sure where am I in
not with this suit oh okay I don't even know where the sea glide is maybe I've already came across
though jeez I'm 800 meters away from fun right let's keep going what's this
it's not very textured which makes me think I'm not supposed to go further in the green sea
it's land oh I can put my little flip flops on it right come on then let's go
I don't like that there's a filter before I can see what's underneath
right is this it land solid land
okay let's pull the lens if I can even make it in time I feel like I'm just gonna have to
like constantly keep coming up and down and up and down
um
some salt some stalagmite
it's kind of far so it doesn't load the texture properly okay
I don't see any new items to pick up
I can't look like a skull oh it's like glowing egg
it's purple down here oh that's cool you know it reminds me of that sky room location
black reef I think it's called okay I remember now
black reach it's like that underwater but everyone he's actually really like I think it's cute
okay hold on let me oh Jesus okay oh hello what is this
oh am I gonna drown hold on what oh my gosh hello oh my gosh okay I understand why there's birds
now that explains everything look at my little flip flops on the sand
okay that's fine fucking back off didn't you tell me the ones on land are scary too
a minion plant is fucking minion look at it disgusting absolutely minion a voxel shrub
what about the voxel astro so I can just scoot about around in the water
a jaffa cake what in the brish island is this is this a joke is everything named after something
brish I'm being trolled this thing is one big troll what let me get a speckled rattler
like a speckled egg from the classic cadbury's easter egg line a pink cat mushroom don't mind
if I do fucking on you come I'm getting high on LSD I don't know anything about you what is going on
on this island oh we're claiming
okay there's a lot of bridge here right we're going up there to scan shit unless this is the path
this is the way to victory to victory oh this is another oh my god someone's look out
is there humans can I talk to humans
hello I am a traveler I come from my ship that blew up Arora
and I would like to invest them and get your lab please oh there's another one
oh can I mate and recreate recreate the populous oh no that one's came off its hinges right I
saw I've been it's nice it's been a while you can sprint oh right okay sorry I didn't realize
you could run I was in flippers okay I was in flippers I didn't think you could run in flippers
you know I thought I'd kind of like twat myself and fall off the mountain pass you know right let's
go up here who dare makes noise in my present
whoa okay hello
is that blood please be honest
are you joking disinfect
oh
this is the first time I've seen sunlight in months
oh no time in the deep I've been dreaming of it
mail and stream
I'm finding it hard to enjoy alone father was right
we should never have left this place buildings don't believe so they we all
do
they do not want us down there despite my best efforts ill health is taking hold of me
the visions are getting worse
Rangary and father are now part of the ecosystem of this incredible planet
it's reassuring to know that when I go I'll join them until then well there's always the view
uh what oh sorry Rowan needs again again
whoa no I don't want to learn how to make a lantern tree are you trolling
an observatory sure let me learn how to make an observatory
he's the fertilizer
there no be
fair and plan oh
nah I'm not wasting the battery on fucking this push right
do you harvest oh what does lantern fruit do
it's edible well I don't eat so
uh if it's not these oh I'm stuck if it's not these pods then
oh a bulkhead sure give me a bulkhead
you can go see
I can't grow your seed actually this one
um right I guess we're going on to that one
oh god I'm a I'm freaking
I'm a kilometer a kilometer
right there's one down there please do not break my ankles on the way down and before that's how
I die in the game not by a freaking reaper um but breaking my ankles going down a hill
and it's very on par for me oh there's a box again
um
what the fuck is that
identify yourself friend or foe identify yourself your little crab thing you
by the way you're running at me fuck me where to go your little thing you
fuck me fuck me come here one by one when you scrub yeah that's right you better fart in the air
is that your only attack oh you got ow you only got that for me huh yeah that's right we stab you
I wish whoa did I hear another one oh no oh that's right that's right welcome to London average
London experience fuck you bitch right let's see whoa I hear another guy
am I about to get jumped on this fucking island please be real
I hear him is he in the pod I think he's inside it
scan the life force oh that's my light hold on hold on small brain very small brain
cave crawler well you're certainly running a fucking cave where you specimen
UPDA
bacterial infection bright green blisters forming networks around the site pathology suggests
a waterborne bacteria incapable of penetrating the body through the skin and respiratory system
underlying indications of genetic mutation and aggressive behavior the bacteria in itself is
unlike anything so far in human warning maybe cautious avoid do not under any consume the flesh
I don't have a fucking plan on it too
sure why not don't make me go inside smile don't make me go inside
it's very loud a rifle we're going to war
war
what was that for that a spotlight
I can hear him going absolutely fucking mental
do you think I got new integrated pda data
you print acquired
data don't multi-purpose room
I got a stun gun is that it oh god that is blinding I'm so sorry if you have epileptic
seizures fucking close your eyes what the fuck is this game dead do you want to slow down the
fucking strobing effect maybe
is he in there
where is he
I can hear him going
is it in the ground
or is it the game fucking with me
I feel like it's a game fucking with me
can I play it no don't aim to read oh there you go
even scratched
don't fool around with it it might be worth something is that supposed to be scott
I think we're gonna crumble to dust it would have done so when I think
any fool around with it maybe we're something we're not the first people to come to this planet
people maybe could be aliens could be the damn sea monsters for all we know one thing for sure
we ain't gonna find out but stay in here
bash stay in here no
ultra glide fins that seems worth it
sorry that thing's fucking is it invisible
honestly I wouldn't put a I'm probably gonna die to an invisible monster real
there you are Jesus
you've been put an ape shot bro
let's go over here
oh I like the detail that you can hear like all your um oh well
okay that noise needs to calm down that you've just discovered something noise needs to
wrap it up wrap it up you are exploding my eardrums I don't know about you guys but my
eardrums are getting exploded by it a thousand meters down I can't even make it down to 200
without perishing and you want me to go a thousand fucking meters down a new pda moment data you need
the purple tablet wait did I not pick it up I mean I can always go back it's not a problem
I was trying to go to that third observer true and you know observe it there that one
how'd I get up there new pda data literally
congrats you have a new pda data new data unlocked like fucking relax Jesus absolutely
relax thank you there are more and you can make purple data
I don't I need food what are you oh the greenest foods right there's no point
someone else can eat it I'm
okay
hello anything in here ready to jump scare me no oh right are you ready
I'm right new pda data
um right what are we looking at log one
right let's hear it this island is a godsend look out of the window no predators fresh food
no building materials nothing left of the ship and your kid says we're gonna starve without more
grow beds speak up kid it's true father the natural growth rates too slow to keep supporting it
all I'm saying is oceans got us surrounded no use hiding sooner or later we'll get our feet wet okay
so your life may have been a fight made up but I've made my decision you want to forfeit your
emergency paid to take a swim go ahead believe me I'm thinking of it damn she doesn't like me
so did I not play this one you see chief you brought us to this sodden planet told us we'd
see a lush payday now what do we got some six weeks later a dead crew a habitat that's half
oh it went bad washed away it went bad executive decisions would be better left to someone with
your extensive experience of hidden people in the face I know enough not to take unscheduled
detours to uncharted planets that's something you don't want to learn the hard way to judge a
decision in hindsight or is no the first one a crash here plan of your own going already take what
we can carry and hunker down in a cave somewhere a scout at a site a couple hundred meters deep
lots of metal deposits how do you imagine we'd live with ready access to building materials like damn
queens a couple of water filters a bio reactor fish but chief we'll eat seaweed salad and drink our
own urine if that's what it takes oh all the matters is all right beer girls come down send the
coordinates to my pda i'll review your proposal he's supposed to be so i'll review right um
i definitely do not have what is necessary right do i need to pick up that purple data thing
down there again because i'll do it i'll go explore and i don't think i want
you don't think i will go explore yes who goes there identify yourself
sorry that was weird gimley just came into my room and burped on the night that was weird i
don't know why she did that okay let's fuck up spiders
okay let's let's not die due to the slipping and sliding let's not perish
after all we've been through but a cheeky bit of a slip and slide
what does this do oh it didn't do the sound effect there you go i did it for you
what is that ancient alien tablet what the fuck is going on in this map
alien tablet am i going to min or did i read that right
i'm not saying it was aliens but aliens is that what the disease is in my body
it's no zombies it's aliens oh my god i want to get to the bottom of this and i want to go though
yeah all right what am i supposed to do i can use the letters here oh no
thank you game please knock it off please game i'm begging you i'm on my hands and knees please
stop what was it this one did i play hit maroon
oh let's really wrap it up
hammering on the roof
someone check if he's actually got us
a stable source of food such a food education is paying off sooner than i'd anticipated
i'd anticipated our only problem is made up made a lot of mess thank you i'll be here a week
i say she's finding excuses to risk our lives made a lot of excuses to risk our lives
i didn't know all i say let's go judgment she makes things go from bad to worse
if she had my experience she'd have more faith humans have spent millennia specializing
in how to shackle nature to our will this planet won't cause us any new problems
my one task now is to keep us alive as comfortably as possible until the insurance
the insurance company
right what uh a battery for me you shouldn't oh are you ready
right that's enough knock off knock off we're not doing that anymore
and charge when you take charge of yourself say chief chief watch you know how to drain those
grow beds of 40 months insurance companies are right from the air sorry um you stopped your tone
2012 and you didn't report it your insurance is void okay then if tomorrow you're gonna be so hungry
you start wondering what it takes like let me lower the s effects yes actually yes instead of
that should uh
do you understand me i'll ask you coming chief not in time i'm staying here neither this rain
keeps falling sooner or later this place will be buried only choice we got is whether to get buried
buried right what's
audio cheeky bit of audio
what's just uh what is it that's making the boom ambient no can you be that's not what ambient
music there's no s effect is that ambient is it music just pop it down like a wee bit there
that's it it's just it's just every single time you learn something new it's just boom sorry there's
a pathetic one don't look at me i'm embarrassed i'm just scanning everything in case uh i think
that may be all on this island unless i'm weak pathetic hey that was gimme that was me me if it
was a 10 out of 10 i'd be claiming it but sorry that was clearly gimme them oh my god there's holes
i love holes um right was there anything super secret
before uh go back down in the lulu lagoon oh my god do you think they paid 75 dollars can i
jump off this without dying like as in cannonball can i cannonball right i'm gonna cannonball
cannonball i like that had to make sure it's saved before for you know we we aren't uh
we're getting in trouble with that one right is there anything special under y'all let's just
check before we go swimming underneath but uh okay so now that we know there's been previous people
on the planet we now know there's fucking aliens i also know that i'm infected let's see what the
rate of fucking infection is let's go i know my hair covered up some of that that said infected
in red uh that said big old infection in red
um and what would uninfect me i'm not sure yet um
um but anyway let's go cheeky 360 i'll see what's going on down here i already forgot what was
a core what was down here big big picture again it's getting
she has ligma i actually i can't believe that ligma's the only way they can take out right
these were the balls i was using to gait me last time maybe you take me come no balls come hither
where would you like to take me what way is my fault but it's that way so i wanted to go this way
i scan these
anchor pod
and just my phone oh look at that wiggly worm he's so crazy oh something red i can harvest
ruby you're coming with me i don't know what i'm gonna use you for come with me wow there's
like everything oh there was something down here right i go up for oxygen but i could have sworn
oh there was something i was gonna go to or was that another location the debt this is for
diamond okay right we're gonna go back to the pod and we're gonna make all the way
lifeboat thingies and you're all gonna tell me where they are okay because i have no clue
am i gonna make it or am i gonna like bump my head on the rock and doubt
oh dear i got a bit uh got a bit carried whoa don't stop fucking randomly in the middle put it away
you say 30 seconds but i don't believe you hen
right pull out the wiki faster than you pull out your
okay right let's take a little detour to the left because i'm not be laying in it because
i already know that reaper's gonna so we're gonna go to the pod we're gonna make our little bits
and bobs and then we're gonna try and do something i don't know what you need to find how to craft
the inflatable fish thing that can launch you to the surface oh i can and i don't have to do the whole
bring me back in
oh i like that the cloud texture's coming back for the green seed do you see it oh wait
i love brand traditions it will let you surface much faster it's pretty helpful okay yes
we will focus on upgrades for the next wee bit and then i don't know what next you'll have to
tell me i don't know no i don't know no
yeah this is definitely the green seed so if we do from the ship from its butt
seven o'clock is the green seed six o'clock is reaper way back in the night whoa don't do that
oh my god i just fucking parted my cheeks i'm so sorry uh i have my foot on my butt cheek and
when i got scared i curled my toes and it spread my butt cheeks oh that like that was like a double
jump scare in real life excuse me excuse me look at that scared me i'm so sorry
that's why i got so scared there i was like who who goes there identify yourself free flying
oh there's a chest
oh
why is it oh my god it's the sea glade i need one more of these oh we found a location uh right i
need a box oh it's about to get dark but we found a location shit a box a box a box a box
and it's about to be fucking night time fuck where is it
the other one has to be near here i'm gonna lose this location though if i don't find it like now
unless what 265 meters away fucking to the green sea which is seven o'clock from the hall back
oh come on why don't me i'm getting scared no i'm scared i want to go back
yeah and i've got them we bastards playing with mail piece of ghost
right i'm gonna have to come back during the day sorry but i mean oh i can't do that you're not
let's do that one um right 265 meters to the green sea i can do that i can do it
i can do it i can do it 265 meters green sea let's make a compass in the pod
you tell me this piss is for the cump huh you tell me a shrimp fried this race oh no
and i want noodles i shouldn't have said that oh i want noodles and my chinese aunt is and
she doesn't open up shop for a bit oh radio message
hi priority automated messages from aurora live pod insert in coordinates attach live
pod this is carrying high priority passenger yoki kasa yoki kasa why do i have to record this
anyway send the immediate burial detail signal location uploaded to pda thank you i guess he died
right i'm gonna keep the alien tablet on me oh this is full of shite fuck everything's full of
shite i'm full of shite right piece off right don't get distracted okay it's steven harkin
i want to go to the island why won't you let me go herbal tablet an ion cube and food i'm in
is this what you're on about floating device that pumps air into pay oh no that's not what you're
um right a wiring kit right i've forgotten how this works again
a wiring kit enamel's glare a stalker too oh so i could have harvested the behind
give me a moment let me cook right wiring kit is what i need right so i'm making a wiring kit
give me that and then let's make a compass right and we're pissing on our cum and we're coming on
our piss right and i want what happens with the compass please compass heading right and then
we're gonna go back into the water and we're gonna find the schematics for the next mother
thing we need right we're just gonna enjoy the evening though right we're gonna enjoy it you
can't kill them and harvest their teeth i got muted and i wasn't even in the pool
we should be able to find the sea glide yes 50 meters east from the pod right i'm gonna wait until
daylight
that's right i'm the actual car weasel voice actor
because that shit don't feel right
10 minutes since last sleep uh yeah that's right take that uh
do you guys think you could carry me to the end of the game being honest i'm actually really
enjoying this do you think you could carry me to the end of the game is this possible
it's possible
who goes there but not in the stream are you gonna finish that cross on jimmy jimmy are you
craving my chicken not strongy we can carry you even to the altar oh that was so cute
uncreative mode maybe wait dany to swap modes
i could swap mode jimmy bezu oh is emmy streaming okay no don't swap no oh no you don't want okay
okay i'll take like two three hand carrying streams okay it's getting pretty tense mommy
jimmy cool you don't crave my chicken nuggets she's uncreated mode already no i'm not i'm not
creating mode i'm on freedom because i'm Scottish freedom
okay oh no it took out the other oh there okay 300 meters 250 meter depth
hmm right uh 50 meters from the east
okay that was a terrible backflip 50 meters east one two three 50 this is already here
reathland is it the habitat
hmm it's not here
then you be farting in my territory is it in this hole oh it's a tight fit
we fit though
oh found gold sure oh that's close when it's so tight
but come on
do you remember the pink caves that's where it is oh shit the purple cave
hmm
it's in the pink caves oh fuck a little to the east a little to the east is a crash box
crash box come here
is it that maybe it's her habitat
uh oh i see the crash say oh we bet oh fuck the reapers in this direction repo
i'm not doing that go away right it's in here right this is where that we shark thing is in
the water the sand one is that the reaper noise there that boom boom boom boom boom
boom
a beacon give me the beacon is this what i need a beacon beacon these nights
beacon of these months reaper isn't that far out there's sea glide wait i'm here did i make it
where oh god where
oh god hold on this this south south you want me to south wait never mind
give me all excited
um it's a cool game you might try it it's fun i just don't want to go in a closer you know
don't want to don't want to press w you could go to life pod three life pod three
where's that chicks in this one actually i'm not too close to the reaper
i don't know yet i'm trying to i'm trying to ascertain if the reaper can get me from here
because i'm going to start screaming lower your volumes i'm warning you now okay here's the purple
cavern purple cavern a laser cutter i already have that
you're safe okay i'm safe in the purple cavern got it 100 meters oxygen efficiency decreased
oh fuck i don't have my rebreather because of the fucking radiation
i'll be it oh my god those fucking eels attack don't they fuck
fuck oh my god mummy scared oh my god the eels go inside the fucking
wait i should have saved fuck i should have saved hold on let's go back up
hold on hold on i'm gonna go save it on the surface because i think i might drown there's
a very high chance of me drowning i'm gonna be honest very high chance so let's just save first
so we don't get annoyed at me husky thank you for the tip i'm ever gonna go death i'm happy
for it to be me no you need to lower your volume 30 seconds okay let's save and then let's go down
that's all we have to do save down save down save down save down and maybe joker no i've gotten
lucky so far with the oxygen situation even like i almost drowned like all the time okay
oh wait sorry okay okay let's go i have my scanner how does the cuttlefish drown you
don't want to know man you don't want to know the things i've seen man oh wait i got a schematic
for faster flippers maybe i should have upgraded should i go back
too much ink i think i should go back i think i might drown there's a very high chance of me
drowning unless there's air in here which i doubt there's no eels here that are interested in me
i am not the fuck this is drowned no i'm gonna drown fuck i can't do it
oh oh no no no no thank you no thank you no thank you pleasure doing business with you
no thank you though oh i fuck i'm drowning to be honest you don't do the jelly cave until
you have the semo 30 seconds that was reaper why is reaper here not hardly even nor
can i controversial can i do this
uh um uh-huh
no no no no no no fuck you no thank you that one right let's go do the flippers
and then we'll go do that upgrade and then we'll go in jelly cave because mommy's not very smart okay
frame perfect look i don't drown in these games i'm just too good at them literally frame perfect
you're welcome
that couldn't have been closer yeah you like it on the edge you like when it gets intense
sweet sweet oxygen
nice deep breath
right let's stop fanny and about here
haven't discovered that i am trying my best to discover it it's not happening that's okay
right no we're done i just need to discover this fucking last ingredient
right
north northwest that's far too deep 175 centimeters oh wait
no flippers flippers i'm here for flippers don't get distracted shit flippers
did i not unlock
then uh did i just make that up
you need to upgrade the table you need a modified station upgrade
and the thing what's flipper modification station right and how do i do that
you need a base as long as it's flared i don't see why not i'm up for anything
and how do i make how does one make a base a beaten
uh you build it with that too
i don't have a tool i need a new tool
repair flashlight flare pathfinder survival habitat builder
i don't know what computer chip is
what is the computer chip now do i make it how does one make a computer chip in the ocean
okay a computer chip
a table coral
i have copper wires i've got a surely i have copper wire down here somewhere
uh-huh
you have copper on your person
i'm so confused right now
right hold on i can do this i can do this i'm a brave girl
a wiring kit right and in order to make a wiring kit
i need two silver ores okay do i have them oh i have one lovely
so i need to go back and find some silver fucking
or surely i drop the deposit of silver or surely
okay it's okay i love gathering the same resources over the work
silver and silver we're just silver spawn i don't even know if i can titanium
soft titanium now it's not the time silver okay i got it i got it i got it i got it
okay right i got what i wanted let's go let's go let's go okay okay i have the silver now what
is this how everyone plays like they have to constantly go back and forth like because i feel
like the right make a microchip
table coral
are you table coral there's no coral in the inventory did i not fucking harvest coral
are you table coral you're coral true no this one did i make you into something
i'm losing it
okay right i can't it's not whatever the fucking fishes in my inventory right
okay
get out of here table coral look for a coral shape like a table there's no way
look for a coral this your coral is red
oh my god oh my god oh my god we're gonna craft it
oh my god we're crafting so hard right now oh my god
oh my god if i have to computer chat
oh we just need a wiring kit okay so we just need another silver which is in here
oh my god
fuck i'm crafting so hard right now
oh wiring kit wiring kit wiring kit
okay and then i can make the fucking habitat builder oh my god okay okay
out a little bit
right of withstanding extreme environmental conditions
right so take the fire extinguisher fish oh i want this instead i don't quit that
that's what we're here to
wait what where is it
what is it not tool repair scanner habitat builder you right you swap out for the
fucking fire extinguisher right and then now what i do
use
that can't be correct i'm out to do it outside
i'm out to do it outside save go outside and use it and i like i've pimp my raid
oh yeah oh yeah i'm struck
and how do i get inside
one it may be prudent to separate work and leisure spaces to maximize productivity treat this space
as your home but never forget that it is not all right then just right and then you need to
build a door open the door right head up use open the door
the door
open the norm what wait why can't i find the door hold on on it
door
hello hatch hatch okay hatch as you come from hatch right titanium watch me not have titanium the
moment i need it but it wouldn't stop like shitting itself out the weather
i'm scared so i'm going in the pod
that's right above me um if i got titanium in the inventory
i just noticed every time i get out of the war it flaps on the ground
in a new way right what's the radio mix let's go in
this is azi from the cafeteria what the hell guys they didn't want us this might happen
our pod was almost crushed by the seamoth bay on the way down now we're hanging on
the edge of a cave system and this grim-looking snake thing is trying to eat through the hole
yeah that sounds about right signal location uploaded to pda
yeah
blade pod 100 meters stranded near cave system and under attack wow okay i like this i like that
it's helping me being like hey you dumbass go find these sites thank you jeez pre-recorded by the way
that's a lot of playthroughs to be honest getting resources for new things make
they need more of the same repeat oh i forgot about the snake no i don't see that i already
met the snake okay i just need to figure out where my titanium is that's where i dropped like
boat loads of this shit are you tighten your copper glass i dropped so much titanium i'm gonna
metal salvage find you when metal salvage it is i will go to take your reek take turn off i
don't have infinite lights there there's your metal your titanium
um
hi you're cute and sweet stuff it paid a lot to look like this
right why did i need titanium oh to build ship right build a hatch first things first a hatch
use use and then a hatch
oh all right then oh we've got constructed right now what oh yeah i got an achievement did you
hear that right cancel that bit negative one to hull strength it's no 7.8
warning emergency power only oxygen production offline i can't breathe in here that's hilarious
uh oxygen
oxygen pumps oxygen from a powered habitat and a pipe oh right okay i guess let's go outside
fucking hell let's try again excuse me uh right oh thank you math for the 10 gifted memberships
congrats to those who cut away your face please enjoy what did it do uh air pump
what does that do
did i just put oxygen in it or are my you need power
i'm not how much solar panel for electricity
solar panel oh surprise surprise titanium the one thing that we didn't need for ages
and i we need it all of a sudden yeah say no more say no fucking more i know no i know what you're
on but i know this game is mocking me thank you game math thank you for membership enjoy the
most of those who've caught it how does it work right no stop getting distracted press that one
then press solar panel
is that gonna work here is this still gonna work or do i need to like put it up you know
i just don't work okay here we go
oh it's making
second one say no
hello welcome aboard captain power is 92 why would it go left
we did it the game's complete right right let's get down to business i need to get the
constructor fabricator nine thousand i've had enough at looking at fish for one day i'm no
building an aquarium modification station is that what i need
um now you can build stores walkers walkers and i so proud yeah so i don't know what it is
wait we won kind of a little bit possibly
um
we've completed the tutorial because you know we've just unlocked the last tool that we need
uh right we're gonna go to the base that's like 100 feet this one 17 easily do 17
oh wait i'll heal up first sorry i'll heal up first and then we'll do 17 and i'm
think we'll maybe learn something new did i get any radio no no that one this one thank you
and items i mean
right put the rebreather on because we're moving away from this okay save yes agreed right and
then we'll do the 100 meter one here we stab him again i'm gonna cut you don't think i won't
i'll cut you that one's 175 we actually might be able to do that one we may be able to
do it now
my back i'm swimming in the people
reward i don't think there was any issues with this reef one
i'm like we're fine humanity ones are pretty cute oh there he is don't ai lock onto me you little
shit i'm on too we're going on an adventure into the green sea thankfully we've actually already
been in the green sea so i'm not too worried about it maybe we'll find the missing piece for the
sea glider i would love was that that's my will is my will thank goodness
i hate when the music gets intense like that
you're gonna give the reaper a Glasgow smile no Glasgow cares
if i didn't mention that i've put that into a short that's coming out i'm like and a
glad we didn't kiss it's not a kiss it is a headbutt
whale his friend he looks he's very nice he gives resources on his back
there's that horrible thing i see him already
okay so i did come across this one but maybe i missed something from it and that's why i'm being
led here oh yeah i missed the pda oh ready vine boom sound effect
integrating new pda data i'm just checking
let's hear it let's hear it
how's his log it's the day of the crash i don't know what the heck is happening i'm scared and
i'm not going outside there are shadows in the water under the hatch but i can't tell if the rocks
are aliens and there's weird-looking caves nearby
the aurora was carrying everything needed to build the base gate
our vehicle bays by react as propulsion cannons it had a cinema there was a zero g gym my cafe
i don't understand how we're here now don't know why no one's coming for me
you didn't pay your insurance
that sounds right the Scottish way oh how did i miss this i've definitely not
explored this i must have perfectly avoided don't ask for the laser pen i'm gonna cry
right okay
okay
when you try your best whoa ask them for this but you made the cutter did i
ah go away
did i
do
wait that's it deja vu have i been in this place before higher in the seas i don't
know where the fuck i'm going you need diamonds oh fuck yeah fucking bastard diamonds
hmm
nope you're getting cough in the south but i'm bonking my head on it can i zap myself
when you get what you want when you get what you want but not what you need is that the song
i'm going back down i feel like there's more uh has to be more or is it really just behind the
fucking diamond diamonds are in the deep cavern you can swim into the wreck oh but can i
bonk like explore it oh my god i'm so skinny okay hold on i've not been taking enough ozampic
oh whatever oh okay okay okay nothing there nothing there that's okay though
not everything has to have something and i you know what i'm saying sometimes it can be
hmm i'm trying to scan anything i'm getting nothing back
uh bio reactor fragment sure oh we're just kind of
there is a hole on the side of the door yeah you would be good at finding the hole wouldn't you
there's a hole on the side of the door i'm looking for a hole on the way up for more oxygen oh
you can't wait to electrocute myself due to my own stupidity take i am sure
use a repair tool okay okay let's go get some oxygen
oh i'm stuck can i get out please oh shit who is attacking me honestly don't be so rude oh it's you
yeah i don't think i can't hear you
he's like locked on funny right i do have a repair tool so i can repair that bit in the hole
he's stuck touch the sparks it powers you up stop it gives you electricity and powers in the ocean
i'd be so pee i'll literally get you i wonder what their d spawn oh wow he already d spawn
it was good
i don't know swimming i knew i swam in here oh you're pissed fuck off
make damage power you
i like that repair tool
i'll get ready to shine something oh my god this is so disorienting holy fuck
oh my god oh my god this is so weird why is it doing this
ah i'm like tilting my head
oh fuck i'm gonna drown holy shit oh no i'm stuck i'm lost fuck where did i come in oh my god stop
this is disorienting holy fuck oh can i please breathe oh please let me breathe
right you need to shut the fuck up all you're doing is snarling next maybe weirdo
i don't even know where you are oh my god that was so confusing right we're going back in don't
worry we'll go back in we'll go back in we're ready if you want you could make the air bladder
that's how it is called
okay we have plenty of oxygen look inside then box that was so disorienting like so quick
like because i was tilting on an axis obviously like going up isn't up when you're not up let's
try this again can you i think he's a part of the fucking structure i can just hear him growling
right look in the box look at that one
you're glowing
oh this is like so twisty are they i feel like the game devs have done something to make this
like super twisty
wait there's nothing here just fucking whoo don't
i've been trolled there's nothing here
oh
this is what i wanted oh we did it
we did it we did it we did it we did it we did it we did it we did it
I did it!
I was about to die, you know how to do shit.
Let me get out.
Oh, it's a fucking tight fit.
Oh, yeah.
Imagine if I dried it after that, I was going to say, bro.
Okay, right, we're going back to the pod,
and then we're going to make this.
Another thing accomplished.
Fuck yeah.
Okay, we were going to craft this,
and then we can make stuff,
and that stuff is going to help us get further down
to discover more stuff.
And with that more stuff that we discover,
we can kill our biggest enemy, the Reaper!
He's our worst enemy.
He's my lifelong enemy.
Enemy, enemy, give him an enemy.
I love the whales.
They're so cute.
A lot of jelly whales.
Jewels?
That Reaper.
Spank.
Spanked into oblivion, honestly.
Wait, no, don't get distracted.
Don't get distracted.
I was about to go there. I'm like, no, no,
we're crafting stuff in our little house.
The whales from whales.
It's a cat.
I'm going to kill all the Reapers.
How many Reapers are there in game?
Just out of curiosity.
No other reason.
That's why my hands are wet.
You already...
I'm supposed to kill it with this fucking tooth.
Just talking about the damn thing makes me jump through.
Jeez.
I'm fine. I'm fine.
He's okay. He's okay. I'm fine.
Just talking about it got me on edge though.
I'm a donkey on edge.
There's 25 in game.
Oh, you're bleep.
Isn't all of you wet right now?
It's like a weird movie quote.
I think it's from Spider-Verse.
And he was like, and that's why my hands are wet.
No other reason.
And I still can't figure out what the punchline of the joke is.
Welcome aboard captain.
Welcome aboard indeed.
No, open up the tool and then start crafting.
Anyway, I start crafting.
How does one obtain diamond out of curiosity?
I don't know how I'm doing so terribly.
I genuinely don't know how I'm struggling to find this one thing
to fucking...
by mining it.
The deep cave.
The cave that I can't breathe in and run out of oxygen in.
That's a hand dryer joke.
Diamonds are a bit deeper. You need to go into the pink cave.
But I'm gonna drown in the pink cave
because I can't find the fucking...
body bastard bitch fucking...
the rest of the blueprint
for the sea glider.
Sea glider, I hardly even know her.
Where the fuck is...
Right, go and give me an actual...
I have a compass, alright?
Tell me where the fucking sea glider is right now.
It's in the shallows, right?
I'm not leaving until we get there.
I'm not leaving until we get the fucking thing.
Where is it?
Tomo!
You alright, Brian?
Why'd you say it like that?
Thank you the very Lord.
Demon.
Check around the kelp forest.
The kelp forest that's north, right?
Or the one that's southeast.
There's two kelp forests.
A demon.
Country room.
Check.
To the place where I belong.
West Virginia.
Mountain Mama.
Take me home.
I'm taking you home.
Yeah, I'm coming home so hard.
I just look around, there's dozens of them in the shallows.
Right, so Ken, how you're...
That's actually just seeing activations at this point.
There's tons of them in the shallows.
There's tons of them.
You just have to look for them in the shallows.
Ken, what I'll look for.
You're fucking frosty. Bend over.
Where is it?
Right, this is the end of it, right?
So I'm going to go up for water.
I'm going to come back down, okay?
I'm about to be nighttime just to ruin my day even further.
Of course it's the one that goes in the direction of the reaper.
What is that?
A creature's egg.
I'm going to leave that alone because it's nothing to do with him.
There are diamonds down in the geyser.
Oh.
I can fucking see it.
Now I'm getting all scared.
Oh, do we have...
Oh, this one.
We have...
Oh!
I'm searching for the same fucking item for three fucking hours.
Fuck off.
Right, I'm not doing that. I'm going to daytime.
I'm going to daytime.
I want coordinates.
I want northeast, southwest.
I want never eat shredded wheat.
I want it.
And we're going up.
We're going to search in the daytime because I haven't got enough battery.
Okay?
Oh wait, was there a radio signal?
Sorry, I think there was a new radio signal.
Hello.
This is Sunbeam.
You know Aurora.
The heart rate jumped today.
What are you saying there?
No bad without the good.
No good without the bad.
I see the good and the bad.
That only means you're overdue.
We'll hold on to the ladder.
Might just be we're in.
We're scanning for somewhere to park.
We'll be in touch when we find it.
The music breaking down over our radio song.
Say...
Who's Birkin, honestly?
I went to 100 beats per minute during the moon.
Did I actually?
I'm trying to like spake my heart rate right now.
What?
I guess my body reacts so...
What the fuck?
Don't be scared.
Wait, what's Juno's voice line?
Do one star jump?
I mean sure, I'll move.
I'll move.
One star jump.
I can jump up and down.
I'm wearing clothes so you're not going to hear anything.
What was Juno's voice line?
What was the end of her voice line?
Do not panic.
I see the bad and good.
I see the good and bad.
Please, I can't take it anymore.
That's the best part.
Because you are going to keep taking it.
Like the good boy, I know you are.
This is my life for a week.
Right, sunlight.
We'll have our head in the coral next to the repo.
So can I go to the coral that's not next to the repo
and get this done part?
This is a bad day for denialings.
Real answer.
Can't believe...
Imagine not winning that overwatch.
I don't know.
We'll read some marshmallows while we wait for the sunrise together.
So romantic.
Oh, it's just me screaming and clip.
I think you can switch the battery from any two
into the flashlight.
I don't know how to do that.
What's this?
I wonder what that is.
I've actually not fully upgraded myself.
You can that.
What would that be?
If that's the compass, it wouldn't be like putting down markers.
It would be something...
What?
What would a chip do?
I don't know.
Can you load your battery with a gun?
Is Mum denying that there's something in there?
Oh, wow.
It is reload like a freaking battery.
I mean, I'll reload the flashlight when we need it.
As I said, if we go diving in the water
during the daytime.
There's like five, six sea-glide fragments
of 100 meters around from the pod.
How could it be so bad then
to find them 100 meters from the pod?
I'm just going to pick a direction,
go 100 meters, and then swim
around the pod 100 meters away from it.
Because how could that genuinely be so bad
that I can't find these body fragments?
Is someone pranking me?
I'm starting to feel like I'm being pranked.
By the way, the trash can delete items you put in it.
No, I'm not going to make it.
Right, 100 meters. Here we go.
This is all we need. 100 meters.
Just for some fish.
100 meters.
We just need to look for the e-bots.
E-bots.
Fucking thing, you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Focus, focus.
Your Mum's a focus.
Hmm.
The fragments can be found
in kelp forests in the safe shallows.
Kelp forests, kelp forests, kelp forests.
Right, that's not kelp forests.
Kelp forests is the other one this way.
Kelp forests in the shallows.
Like in a car?
In a cave?
Like this?
Oh, there it is.
I saw that.
That was a stalker tooth. Hold on, I need that to build something.
Hold on, I need that to build something.
Let me get oxygen.
There's a couple.
I see I'm bottom left.
Hmm.
Okay.
Okay, just go for it.
Just send it, send it.
I can send it.
I'm off.
Oh, an inventory is full.
Wouldn't that be hilarious?
An inventory is full.
My thing is so fucking hard right now.
Fuck off.
Yeah, you better fucking rotate, bitch.
Is it gonna come back?
Fuck off.
Fuck off, fuck off, fuck off, fuck off.
Right.
Oh yeah, piss off too.
Good.
I'm trying to jump spear, man.
Is it here? No, it's not here.
Oh my god.
There was another tooth here.
Oh shit.
I need that for something.
I don't know what, but I need it for something.
I just draw a titanium because it's really common.
But these teeth aren't.
What the fuck is it?
I'm gonna fart out of frustration.
I swear it again.
Is it like obvious?
And because it's obvious, my brain is like ignoring it?
No, that's just neat.
Salvage.
No, it's slowly coming.
My god.
No, don't pick up fucking random pieces.
Yeah, you better, ow.
Can we jump out of me, honestly?
Nah, I need it in kelp forest.
Has mummy found anything?
Mummy's done a sweet air fall.
This?
Does it look like it?
I just need one.
Is it you? No.
Yes!
Ah!
Fuck! That took so long.
That took so long.
That took me four hours to find out.
And it was like a hundred yards away.
Right.
So now I go in here and make something.
What do I make?
I don't know what I make.
I don't know.
A sea board thing?
I don't know where I make it.
I don't know.
Hold on.
Is it in here I make it?
Progress that only took me fucking forever.
Copper wire and titanium.
And I've got it!
Fucking Christmas, medical!
Right. Need what?
What did I need?
Titanium and copper wire.
Titanium, go!
Oh, sorry I didn't need to jump there.
Titanium!
Copper, sorry. One, two, and give it a...
Oh no, I fucking have some supply.
Just a few of these supplies.
Nothing major.
A copper wire?
A copper wire.
Okay.
Oh!
Right. And how does this work?
Okay.
Right, let's grab this now.
And then of course I can't just drop fucking shite in here.
It's gonna be too easy.
I'm gonna drop shite here instead.
Fuck you.
I'm not...
Oh my god, you can't just drop...
I swear this doesn't work the way I want it to.
Okay.
Take everything.
Take every single little thing I've ordered to scavenge.
I'm gonna keep the purple tablet on me
in case you somehow randomly come across
the ease of a power swirl.
I'll keep that.
Right! How do I quit the miserable thing?
I don't know.
And I have a new radio signal,
so I assume it's gonna tell me somewhere to go.
Slot one through five.
What did you call me?
Did you just write me?
There's a bit more than just radiation
between...
There's a wee bit more than just radiation
between us, Lava.
Can I show you that much?
Right.
The purple cavern has diamonds in it.
Which is that direction?
And then I can get the laser
and I can go in something.
Okay, now just hold it and swim.
Pod six is a red grassland.
The sharks.
Oh, I've already investigated it.
Mummy can be my slot reel.
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
It's so...
I'm zooming!
It's so fast!
Where's the purple cavern?
Is it not right here?
Toggle light?
Toggle map?
Oh my god!
Wait, where's the purple cavern?
I've lost it.
Is it not on the edge?
I mean, we could just go down to the light pod instead then.
Is that the Reaper of the Honest Wreck?
Fuck it, we're going over here.
I don't know where it is. I'm scared.
Oh my gosh! It's so fast!
Oh, there's the fissure!
One of you told me that in the fissure
there's diamonds down here.
Hold on.
Let it blow!
We're camping a fissure right now.
Are you ready?
Go a little bit too over there.
It all burns?
What? It always burns?
No matter what?
I didn't expect that.
Why are you still going in?
I thought it was a timed event
where you're supposed to go down a little bit.
Right, let's make our way over here.
It's superheated water.
It's a thermal vent.
That makes more sense.
Now, when you put it like that...
Wait, my power is only 91%?
What are you? Did you just spawn in?
Oh, you're playing with metal.
Why do they play with metal?
There's two more.
Scan the boxes.
This one right here.
What is it?
There's something juicy inside.
Mobile vehicle.
The fragments.
God, they love playing with metal.
They're like...
Oh, there's another box there.
Oh, cheeky box.
Mummy, aren't you playing?
No, no, attack someone else.
I'm going for parts.
Give me, give me, give me.
How does this happen?
I didn't have nothing on me for ages.
And then, all of a sudden,
they all come flying at me.
Like...
Even bigger upgrade?
Wait, I'm going back to get whatever this is.
You're saying it's an even bigger upgrade?
We've got a vehicle?
No more smooth brain time.
I'm behaving.
Am I being chased?
Nah, I seem okay.
Okay.
You can make the sea more.
Use your glider for swimming.
Well, I don't want to use the battery up.
The battery...
I can't be arsed getting one.
Oh fuck, that's so much faster though.
Damn, they got me.
They got me. Right, how do I make this fucking mammoth thing?
Oh, with the...
This thing.
Right, drop these, then I need these.
Habitat Builder.
Pop that one.
And then, please make...
Not mammoth thing?
I'm going to blow it off, but...
Is it going to be used? No.
You actually build the vehicle bait in the crafter.
Of course you do, because why wouldn't you smile?
In the crafter.
This.
I just need a lube.
Okay.
One lube. One of these.
And then that's it.
That's like a fidget spinner.
Brain rot.
Lube is required to go ahead.
Right, and what is it?
It goes on the surface?
What is it?
How do I use that?
I can fill up that.
Make it like a food?
And what do you do exactly?
Whoa!
What's that? Claim?
And what do you do? Claim?
I'm already on it. Use for you, puppy.
Lube, lead, glass, titanium, power cell.
Lube, lead, glass,
titanium, power cell.
titanium,
power cell.
Lube, lead, and glass.
Can you... You guys can just count them.
I don't want you to use all your supplies.
Lube, lead,
lube,
lead, glass.
Okay, lube is these.
And I think I have everything else.
If you pin the rest,
you don't need to remember. Oh, they actually fill up that.
I can't believe that. Right, let's take some lube.
Lube, lead, glass, titanium,
power cell.
Lube,
lead,
lube,
lube, lube,
lube, lube, lube, lube.
Alright, let's make lube.
Okay,
bottle of lube.
And then let's check her inventory for the lead.
I did not need that much for lubricant.
Holy crap.
Lube, lead,
I need titanium,
I need 10 titanium for that.
So, one of you,
that's five.
Then,
mm-hmm,
I need five more.
So, of course, it's not going to be
around when I'm looking for it, Tini.
That's why it would be.
Is there any titanium left?
One, six,
seven,
eight, nine,
ten.
Okay,
and ten going to be not here.
Ten.
Don't make me moan, I'll do it.
I think I got a horse.
And, of course, it starts.
I can't do anything.
You can pick up some metal.
Moan, you won't.
Maybe I don't want to boost the light on it.
I can't be arch-crafted in more barriers.
I probably should, though, if we're going
exploring.
Let me guess, this is that thing I needed?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, we have the
titanium.
Yeah, of course.
Literally, of course it is.
Of course it is.
Oh, I should fall and try to go unbanned.
I'm right.
Sorry, I don't know what kind of ultimate shit that was, but...
Okay.
I need four quarts
for glass, right?
Easy, please, don't want to squeeze it.
I do love just dropping everything right at this place.
Under the tree.
Okay, and then the power cell.
So we need to make
two batteries
in silicone rubber.
Okay, I'm...
Silicon rubber check.
And then, if I'm not mistaken, two batteries
which is two coffers.
Two acid
mushrooms and two coffers.
I'll do it.
That's unfortunate.
I only have one.
Another one, please.
Are you called for?
Perfect, and then one of you,
two of you, three and four.
And then we have built the
behemoth, behemoth, behemoth.
Right.
Battery.
Also, hi.
How much are you enjoying the game? It is a good game.
Uh...
Obviously, the only problem is
I'm too dumb to play it, but...
It's not gonna stop me, okay?
Right, is that everything?
A ball of war just tried to jump me, did you see that?
Right, this.
Hello, claim.
Right, claim.
It's gonna make it.
Oh!
My gluteus maximus.
Uh...
Right, before we take off,
I am going to replace
the battery in...
this. I need two coffers.
I need two coffers and four
acid thingamobobbers.
And then I'm gonna replace
the batteries and all this, because
if I'm going to explore in deep, deep depth,
I'm going with
full batteries.
Battery.
One and two, and then we'll go
make our batteries, replace
everything that we need, and then
we're off-ski. We're actually
call me a crystal
Serovski, because
oh, dear lord, we're off-ski.
You'll feel so safe in that.
Okay, right, and then R
to reload.
Oh, I might see.
Okay.
You can select.
Oh my god, so what are we going to do?
Okay, and I enter.
Then click. Okay.
Uh, then...
That's it. Just drop off whatever I
don't need, and then we go in the
behemoth.
Drop that, drop that.
Need to see Glider.
Don't need that right now, don't need that
right now.
We'll take the alien tablet with us, and
then...
What do you do, exactly?
Enter?
Does it update?
Um...
Right, I guess.
We'll go...
Do I need to get batteries for it or something?
Does it...
Does it, like, heal...
Did I just drive by a fish right there?
Did you hear that? I think I just drove
by a fish.
Ran it over.
It uses power cells...
to...
em...
that.
I think I'm going to be wasting that, you know?
A little speed bump.
You will hit fish as you look here.
Hi, Mr. Whale.
Hey, where your wife is?
So, I need to make batteries...
repair with your toolkit.
I have to repair it?
Right.
Yes, you can run over a fish and
suckers, but I'll get damage. Okay.
System error.
Issue detected with playback of
recorded stream.
Oh, yeah?
Starting stream from the beginning.
In five seconds, the streamer will begin
with her greetings.
Stop!
I go, hi, Vodling.
Thank you, pre-recorded stream bot.
This is not pre-recorded for anyone that's lurking
in the shadows. It is a meme.
It's a gag. We say that it's pre-recorded
because I only game for
male attention, all that kind of stuff.
So, my oxygen doesn't go down
at all inside this pod.
Can I, like, drop myself
off at, like, an inspection
site and then put myself back in the pod?
Oh, my gosh. Look at them.
Aren't they fascinating?
They must be aggressive,
but there's so many of them. That's not fair.
Aggressive.
Oh, jeez.
They look so beautiful, though.
Are they aggressive?
Maybe not.
No.
Alright, alright, alright. Relax, relax.
Relax, relax.
What does her thing say?
My...
What is that next one?
No, that one. Fuck that.
can the Reaper gobble me up inside this be honest I did some very German
the Reaper can gobble me in this why I'm gonna have to save and go for it he can
grab you I'm in a tasty mail chomp chomp you're like a peanut leave my small
size alone okay I can't help it I'm just a tiny cute girl I'm only 5 foot 3 I'm
so small I could crush your winkle in the palm of my hand fuck I don't know what
I say you see we're gonna tickle the pods gotta get the minerals in you know
literally it's like a crab you need to shell out the way for the yummy meat
inside oh are we really doing wait where the fuck oh it's is that where he oh
I'm sorry I'm sorry that per thing just finished paying off his mortgage right
we're saving we're sending it surely the Reaper cannot keep up I'm sorry sorry
sorry I'm new to driving Tee-hee oopsie wait where the fuck is this thing on the
ground I'm losing it hold on other I'm gonna lay low I'm gonna lay against the
walls it may be too deep for the moth how is it too deep for the moth he's my
biggest upgrade turn off your headlights you can't take it down to others we
bastard fish where's the purple cave then I seem to think the purple caves
around here oh I'm sorry sorry I'm new to driving forgive me I've just passed
my test what was that whoa is that what I think is is that oh no it's one of them
bastards right there's all ghosts 200 meters is a crush limit oh what's the
point again all these fucking upgrades right we're doing this one then oh hey
you've just unlocked a super awesome upgrade but you can't do anything because
you have to upgrade it further just shoot me just take me out back I love a good
I love a good game too but oh sorry sorry sorry sorry I'm not looking where I'm
driving sorry it's where does that go wait what no here where the fuck is it
oh it's here it's down here if it's I'm from in radiation territory then I'm not
going crazy where is the fucking thing it's here right gently gently easy easy
stop it you're hurting the fuselage okay right let's try this again stop stop
you're bumping everything right if I leave it is it gonna like is it it's just
gonna stay here right don't don't float anywhere I'm fucking trying my best
here okay please I'm trying so much vehicle fish slaughter honestly so much
vehicular fish slaughter under score mama such a violent beast on a floor I
assume once I get inside take your time geez no no no I'm not in a rush at all
oh don't do that oh that fucking scared me the fucking dude in where am I going
sorry did you see that scare me basic double bed well I'm gonna need this right
where is the bit I'm gonna drown in here so I can come in here fuck
fuck fuck fuck I'm out of vote I'm turning back where is it oh please my
savior oh my god please if the eels could not attack me right now that would
be great teamwork from the AI yeah yep I got it I got it I can't breathe I
understand please let me in oh jeez wait I'm full health is it like temporary
damn it fucking we're getting harmonized to in the background remember your
glider oh hardly even though I'm working wait can you hear that wait I can't hear
those sound effects here that one true gentleman okay I heard that one right
use your glider use your glider here can I go in the wormhole curiosity oh my
can go in the wormhole why let's not piss around too much what am I here for
oh I see it see it see it see it right peace of flow jelly that's right I need
to out stop hurting me you know the shit stings right right I need to hear here
we are this is one here for yes I think that's everything in here oh no
there's one here sorry ultra high capacity tank actually real upgrade out
stop please stop touching me okay okay okay two three for what there's a second
PDA on the tank wait back Danny go back in again then you go back in
I need to go back in don't make me go back in third PDA near the tank blueprint
okay I love going back in no I really do it's my favorite hobby going deep and
further it's not scary at all oh you may want to say first like right here right
here near the water tank oh my god a swivel chair oh this is so important
right now near the water I'm stuck you bastard I'm stuck sorry it's on the
where you got the tank upstairs okay first death and it's a freaking jellyfish I
got caught on the tentacle I got caught on your tentacles exactly you lost some
longing well I mean I kept on pouring stuff so do we really care that just
reload quit quit and then reload but the cement is stuck down there so it's
quit and then look quit and then you think you saved fucking got caught in your
tentacle hit it down refling stop playing with it you're gonna go blind yes
okay let's try that again no not that you put that off put that off my face I swear if
that you'll want to attack me now that was really deep not there it's not is this not
it no deeper out stop it I'm getting like stuck on stuff that isn't stuff
I'm like bumping my head on everything was that was that it
might need to rescan the swivel chair it is of the great utmost importance I do agree
actually no you're right yeah that was it all booting tag now let's not get caught on
the jellyfish agreed let's behave let's not get caught on the fucking jellyfish well
something's making a noise and it's no me coming for me yeah yeah pissies coming for
me did you see that welcome aboard captain welcome aboard 64 hell what did you do out
here all right and then let us analyze the voice logs we just got quotes and clues
for your crisis system some catfrogs male hunter is located in the dense grass the damage is
from going too deep you can see that so I'm already a bit back to the older let's upgrade
before we can progress with anything right gently come out very up very gently do not
bump to say no not the anglerfish fuck right we tried we tried sorry it's my first time too okay
right let's go back to the ship how much deeper there's diamonds down there oh piss right okay
diamonds I forgot fucking brain of a I just came out right diamonds diamonds diamonds
or something right it's fine it's fine
diamonds okay but not 200 meters diamonds just diamonds are somewhere here but don't
but don't bump your head but don't go below 200 meters either I see something over there
I need to not go under 200 meters or this thing's gonna explode right let's see
diamond I see that I see the eels are gonna try and bite my
is there anyone online right now by the way a viewer
okay I'm gonna go for this platform I'm off 200 meters oxygen I'm off I've got my
so I need ammo
please have them a battery uh no that was really worth it no seriously come to that again
okay you will be liable to reimburse the full market price your current bill stands at three million
credits are you serious okay that was one diamond that's a bunch but I don't have enough
oh my god that's so disorientating when it does that like little swivel thing
yeah that oh that's making me fucking
I don't get anything
curse you and of course I don't need one diamond I need multiple
did I go there
just let one of them
I really don't want to break who who is hitting who's even getting ran over oh wait no I was just
you're done uh right unfortunately I can't actually spot any diamonds
deal with it
oh the hole's gonna fucking break
wait
I'm not gonna make a
please of course special requirements because why would it be normal requirement
oh thank you right I have two diamond the Christmas miracle
got the sound designers on point no I'll give them that you know what you win this one dev team
the glider oh fuck I'm sorry I remember I remember I have the glider
okay I'm gonna save because we got two diamonds and then we'll go back out with the glider okay
I'm so smart
wait hold on do I have the reading on
oh my god look how fast that am
coming at you with supersonic speech because I'm the
oh I threw fucking radiation
I'm already like out of oxygen
what was that lithium
wait no lithium
did he just swipe at me inside the jellyfish oh shit where am I going
right give me the fuck out of this cavern I'm out I'm done I've had enough
okay how'd I get out
okay look for the crash say that's how I came in
look for the crash say
adenium
I got two diamonds and I got one lithium
high strength is it lithium what you think
that's the crash
maximum death raged
hull damage imminent
I'm gonna shit you fish this thing anyway
fucking 44 health I'm gonna I've took it out once
am I safe to go up
stop out
okay okay okay I have diamonds
so I can do the laser cut thing please tell me there's something good about the laser
if you want to understand do not drink lithium that's very I thought lithium's what we just
seen if you have a really bad imbalance chemical imbalance in the brain
okay right what am I trying to do
uh the repair tool yeah I can do that
the this repair oh you mean this repair tool right here
uh yeah this one
this one right here no don't no take me out
no stop it takes me so long
okay and how do I upgrade that you can
it's not a spoiler all right let's see what you play
uh it'll take us a couple of days to align our orbit should be able to establish direct
contact with you during that time then we're coming in to get you cross your fingers the
weather holds don't leave us waiting um um where
fucking get me in the pod now and we'll just go
wait I won where's my pod okay there is um
did I even need to do anything I mean I've got diamonds
okay the good ending right I even bother about making the laser beam then
I mean I could try and make it a propulsion cannon I'm five laser cutter any self-made sure
why not let's make the laser cutter in case I come across something that needs to
sure
what I guess we'll go and see what this location's all about because yeah
uh where is it not that way oh that way okay
there's another island
we only have 79 battery almost I hope that's not gonna be a problem
then again we do be getting real quick so I'm not sure if it is gonna be a problem
um
do you know you have 30 minutes 30 minutes yeah 30 minutes
don't beach it is that possible I can beach to my own so we've been this way before probably
it's a bit harder to see because there's like more interface in the way
okay this is the green sea what did it just spawn in there I saw that what did you just spawn in there
what was oh sorry sorry I'm still learning how to control this uh it's one done something
stressful oh my god cheat see doodle in I'm cheat see doodle in
oh wait is this the thing I need to get inside
oh is it not it's just crash thing oh imagine if I oh oh you'll never guess what you'll never
guess what watch this oh look at that scale look at that scale make sure you've got your dwee
am I controlling this or is it just going for it oh my god look at that scale
look at that I'm such a wielder I'm such a wielder what's in here show me
ah boom
oh I like how the game gives you a chance if you're a dumbass they're like oh you can just go
that way so it's got fragment sure
where it got it another fragment
yeah of course now that I've got it all of them start showing off everywhere
right let's go in the behemoth where is it
where is it why is there no cross here same way oh there it's oh it's the sea mess not the behemoth
sorry okay here we go welcome aboard captain okay we need to have more of that luck again
that render distance luck yeah let's do more of that let's lock in on that this game is too scary
I thought I mean I did get scared I mean not to get political or anything I may or may not
have screamed at a certain bit but overall heart rate's been on the low side he's a behemoth of a
sea myth he is such a good boy 28 degrees inside oh I just realized my hair is covering up the
temperature gauge should I put myself left honestly the problem is right this is just the green
sea we've been here before oh hello oh we've not been here before yes we're reading marshmallows
for the next 35 minutes don't mind me I do seem to have grown some balls
cannot identify I don't have the purple thing on me thank god right you stay there a behemoth
you've done me so proud thank you hello let me get my knife though because I don't trust the
location at all I go in that can I go in it
oh my god I can't believe we're playing Halo this entire time you guys pranked me
we're playing Halo this entire time I knew you liked the series too hello
hello hello oh my gosh I have what you like
when the alien versus predator is going what the fuck is going on in this continent
scans indicate this structure is composed of a metal alloy with unprecedented integrity
no matches found in database performing structure analysis
hello
hello anyone home I like what you've done with the place it's kind of like alien
dwarven inspiration got the green light oh you look important
you look very important demo data unknown language attempting translation okay alien data terminal
discovered inside an alien facility it is not possible to translate any useful information
however scans have returned some information on the device itself it's likely a solid state
computer although there is no clear way to interface with it on approach it began producing
a low frequency radio wave containing complex but recognizable data patterns it is likely the alien
species which does end this technology evolved or genetically selected sensory apparatus here
and understand the information being broadcast by the device and to communicate back
whales and radials is that what it's talking about the metal process and power required to
perform this kind of telepathy would imply the designs were considerably more psychologically
developed than the common human huh how unique no get face hugged no thank you
hello
anyone home oh i found a key
hello oh
i'm gonna play minecraft oh my god is steven alex they're my favorite
analysis of the patterns on the walls cannot ascertain whether their purpose is aesthetic
or functional whoa further data required
okay
all right i don't trust this i'm like i'm gonna keep my knife out you know for safety reasons
thank you for the cute
mommy i'm scared i'm the one playing the game i'm scared reflin we're just gonna have to cuddle
the more we get the more it can translate
this data set appears to be multi-dimensional schematic by mapping the pattern to three
dimensional spaces possible together basic understanding of the facilities internal
workings this facility this facility's unknown construction material is identified as an ultra
non-reactive oh ultra hard non-reactive metal amalgam synthesized from off-world materials
there is no indication that it can be damaged or destroyed power the schematic indicates the
facility was to be powered by a separate self-sustaining power plant located elsewhere on the planet
the location's not listed but there is evidence the designers intended to harness the planet's
natural thermal energy down the thermal vent she's going in this ventilation truck the facility
consists of the upper engineering section where the schematic was found in the control room which
is accessible via the security sealed elevator shaft or a separate underwater mantle oh
is it literally the vent
i got shacked by a big waterfall so the control room is in the lower section house is the only
known way to interface with the facility however the schematic doesn't detail the
operation procedure or installed screw measures okay that's a lot of work to get i'm kind of easy
uh 29 minutes and help gets here i'm wondering if you're more like efficient with your time
your best probability of interfacing with this facility is achieved by accessing the control
room in the lower section do i jump i mean i'm a gamer so oh i'm getting the good suck
oh i'm getting gently okay
getting a bit deep have to have to get a bit deep you know helps
helps on the way thing force fields control okay
doesn't appear to be anything of significance in the water
do a flip i don't think i'm going to be attacked i think i'm alone so
uh i would like to be outside for when help arrives in case it whoa
are you being rightful starting biological warfare
uh
strong resemblance to human weaponry in form this device must have been designed with a human
eye user in mind whether they they're sending us to war they're putting us to war whether the
aliens that built the structure were themselves human either are otherwise employed what there is
no obviously to remove the rifle from the case oh yeah watch this bonk okay well i'll try
maybe sometimes violence isn't the answer
so i can go up the stairs or i can go down a corridor i guess up this oh i'll take the cube thank
you uh
and there is an end to this at the top whoo hello hi
we got the the locksmith key a skeleton key that's what they call not the locksmith key
whoa alien device what are you
it doomsday device chotto matty scans indicate this device is uh contains enough potential energy
to destroy the entire
total fucking matty um what's going on here hello
uh
okay that's popular uh nanny the hell is going on here likes
i'm gonna put that away again
oh i'm gonna get jump stairs hello control facility hi
oh yeah no enter i'm gonna put my wee finger in it oh yeah it's got my wrist
oh
the control panel is broadcasting a message translation reads warning infected individuals
may not disable the weapon this planet is under quarantine
are you got you got a bandage that kind of fucking hurt i'm not gonna lie
what
disease research facility depths 800 i can't even get to 200 what makes you think i can get to 800
thermal 1.2
we're up to the uh quarantine procedures will be automatically enforced with immediate
this quarantine enforcement platform or target all incoming and outgoing crafters around the spread
that's why no one no one can get off the plant oh no can we radio in sunbeam
oh my god they're gonna get nuked out of the fucking sky
can we call them or something you know a little fm radio moment hey don't land bad idea
bad idea can we tell them not to land i'd rather they survived
okay so there's ale something made a noise there's ale
oh i've already taken it thank you though uh so there's alien tech that's preventing the spread
of a disease understandable have a semi nice day
the alien arch oh my god we're going to the nether
i assure you the only nether i fuck with is my region so i'm a bit scared to progress alien
art this structure intends purposes theories of function ceremonial industrial advanced
teleportation network okay
are you anything is this just a dead end
okay i assume this is just a dead end and i'm not doing it i'm here i'll heal it for you
okay are we about to watch some fireworks because we can't radio in that they should
definitely not come
um self scan go on then
self scan complete bacterial infection in your system is progressing detecting skin irritation
and immune system response yeah further data required to identify bacterial strain
further scan oh wait i didn't hear that
okay
is this how i get out i need to go this way or kind of go up the lift
hey can you guys use that alien tech and give me a lift
oh i guess though right so then what's out here
here you can go both ways i didn't know you swung like that
oh
oh i'm gonna i'm gonna use the front door if that's okay with you i'm just gonna use the front door
yeah i think i'd rather just use the front door
yeah okay let's just that was not fun i honestly thought it was gonna let me explore a little bit
okay well unfortunately i don't think uh sunbeams gonna be
that's gonna be there's gonna be a beam there's gonna be a lot of sun
130 bpm yeah i i know it's hard to believe but i got a little bit surprised there i honestly
genuinely if we're talking like developer wise i thought they were gonna let you explore that
little watery bit out there like i saw that structure and then all here's
bomb in my ear and i'm like can you know
must begin to the front he came out of nowhere that was unlucky
mommy doesn't like us the end of the back door
terrifying
god this game is fascinating though i'm gonna be honest i thought i was gonna hate it i'm like
intrigued now i'm loving this so i'm guessing that's where i was and i could have swam but
you know me oh no me tablet me lucky charms oh i'm to scan it sorry i like that prompts me to
scan it thank you it helps no what does it just give me pieces of it just give me pieces of
oh titanine iron cubes hi million
well i think we have 20 minutes before uh implosion of sunbeam and then we can
proceed with whatever the campaign mode is after that oh there's more to explore on the island
okay i guess i don't need my knife out i don't need to be suspicious like that
uh oh hello little birdie oh an extra tablet oh ppp cute little bird
oh yeah yeah i guess i'm going tall i feel like
ah we're like now the front of the ship okay this is like the kind of like well 11 p.m
maybe a bit more nine oh new oh i was i not supposed to okay sorry the gears holding me down a bit
what's the goal of the game to survive i there is a campaign whatever that campaign is i'm afraid
i'm not familiar i've never placed this before but we'll find out together um there is a countdown
going on no it's not a countdown like that um unfortunately we have just discovered this facility
that purposefully quarantine okay i should not be explored that i thought i was to explore this part
whoops he's just in a 360 um maybe there's something at the top of the island oh my god am i gonna have
to go in the war let's reach the the island as fast as possible shall we whoa i saw that
like kind of lurk on the edge
so what the f***ing attack to me she could get honestly what attack to me
hmm a 19 minute an 18 minute countdown's too long is it
i have to go down i don't have to go up no no exploring the actual mountain bit
hmm
scan a tree both right go up right i'm staying on the i don't want to go too far down because uh
i do you think you can like wave like they'll be orbit in the planet before they land i can
just wave and be like don't come here no save yourself there's a cavern
you bastard i saw you i saw you get over here no no no no you want to fight fight me el manel el manel
that's right that's right that's right that's right that's right spank spank okay three shots
and they're done there's another one ahead
i would like to explore without being attacked please wait are they not aggressive
might want to save okay real and true
wait are you guys not aggressive
or is the ai just oh okay they are aggressive stop it get some help i can't f***ing hit them
oh my god he's actually look at these jukes i'm actually getting wrecked actually jukes
hmm
mommy's a bit scared to go anywhere
oh y'all
mommy's not a fan of it well the good thing is we don't actually need any resources right now so
i'm quite happy to leave the cave if you are oh this is the one the man is the theme is okay
yeah it's just lying there really close by
is there anything else here
is there resource on the wall sure why not oh a diamond
so much pressure i'm so happy and i'm gonna get me some friday
my auntie's not open her shop yet
but then i would have to go outside woes me
i was that what i was supposed to explore around i actually can't see going up
oh unless unless we will ow question mark ow
question mark ow this is the behemoth heal me
where is this i've lost them behemoth oh there you are
do you heal me
no i can't heal myself glass bone turn the lay off she's subbed her toe i did
what i do these cubes i don't know what's with the kitchen
turn that lay off get off
did you repair it yes it is repaired i didn't damage it getting here thankfully
there are things up there i can't quite remember how you get up
maybe i need to scoot around the island i just feel like we're under a timer so i'm like worried
about missing the okay let's save before i end up you know doing a skyrim moment
this no this is not the path i'm claiming this in flippers
yeah i'm claiming this in flippers this is not the path
is it up here
like the little tentacle arm going into the yeah you would like the tentacle arm wouldn't you
slut all right then gee fuck me excuse me for having a special interest uh
okay this is definitely the path up there's literally waste on something like that hello
uh
why do i feel like this is a xenomorph moment
i'll scream don't think i won't everyone lower your volume
okay it's pointing me in the water again so i guess there's a schematic in there that i need to progress
hmm
she's arguing with herself honestly
this is locked in the wall lithium
go
yeah let's take the lithium i feel like i'm going to need that for some construction
diamond i'll take it oh fuck i'm full right we'll drop the titanium because it's just so
common that we don't need it oh look at them rolled in who's going to get there for oh my god marbles
on stream tag yourself what marble are you it's not on youtube yet do you know how crazy i'm going
to go for marbles on stream if i can do it on youtube like i'm going to fucking ape ship
barrel i'm like i'm kidding no i'm going up i'm going up i'm scavenged enough for one day
mate let's get to the top of the hill without going in the hill deal deal
oh shit wait
boost wait why are we doing exclamation mark boost please oh right is that what marbles on stream is
will you chew on them again i told you that story of me chomping on my fucking marbles and confidence
oh jeez son i've no got the fucking hp for this i'm gonna be honest is this where i came from
fuck off
fuck i really have to go in a cave
but mommy's oh tablet
hmm
go jump someone else
i've just done a 360 mods spin that refilling like a whole spin blooping
is this the top top that i was supposed to get to random salt deposit sure why not
all right let's not fall off the map deal deal this is just the dead end there's nothing here
nothing to scandalize
am i still infected i'm pretty can't believe that
okay well i got the purple so
i guess we'll watch the sun beam perish unfortunately
okay let's just get out of the cavern
because uh it is immense immense cavern big cavern big cavern
all right who's ready for some fireworks
how i'm getting so lost
hmm i mean i guess we're good oh fuck oh Jesus right that was a terrible idea don't
let me do that again do not let me cook don't let me cook
cavern i don't see anything harvestable
um
that's the rebeta
seems pretty safe surprisingly ah that'll be why oh oh you're the fissure
unfortunately i don't have the oh i don't have the and that looks like bait i'm about to be
baited this looks like this looks like fucking bait oh here's a here's a pretty little purple
tablet oh for me i shouldn't have
i'm happy uh i guess we'll come back
let's get some air
and i'm lost
and i'm disoriented he he he gonna drown because i can't figure out what left and right is
you hear those roars that's a reaper there's a reaper here and i'm piss arson about in the water
right there's a reaper circle in the island
oh go away they're all scaring me
does he go from uh seameth when he's not doing anything
thank you crazy jesse for the tip as well oh yeah you better be hydrogen and eatin whereas i'm
that far on me i don't see him
as if that's concerned here
yeah not 100 health um i don't know how to increase my health so far away from home
it's in the shelves it usually doesn't come to the surface if you don't attract them
those trees have some dripping holes
some dripping holes oh how did you notice that
i don't even know how you notice that i'm gonna be honest
my inventory's full but what am i making
i have three alien tablets we must be heading to another alien facility
it's gonna land right here right so where's the best view from the facility
right let's get a nice little rooftop view from the facility okay
oh we could stick our head down here just to see a little bit more
oh you would reflin reflin come on just use me
sure no more
just looking right let's get let's get front row seats to the old land and site uh
will they stand on the alien facility since the metal is incompatible
i can't i have to i still have over 24 hours
the best view is at the beach with the building in view oh like from the beach looking here
don't get too close to the building monka monka right i'm off the building
seeing what oh my god the little green stone's lightening
i like how my knife goes it looks like tron
oh you can't see it because i'm in the way but my knife goes like tron look
should we watch tron i think we should
i've not seen the new one
right okay is this the view of the totally legitimate sunbeam that's totally not going to
explode because um yeah i would read some marshy mouths whilst we uh wait for the rescue party
that's right the alien facility spoiled it i read with my own eyeballs if i didn't read that
i wouldn't have known and i would have been hopeful that i was getting through
yes the view i wonder did you guys read that when you were exploring the facility
tron a real you have to watch the 80s one before you watch the 2010 one
closer so you can see the building wait like actually on the spot isn't that where the
thrusters are supposed to go like here like this view let me get it right
i move myself over a little bit yeah i did not until an hour later right there okay for no
particular reason this is the setup look up a bit okay all ready i'll read some marshmallows
or shall we shall we enjoy the clip of me screaming
yeah imagine you're actually getting off the planet and seeing explode honestly
if you read this stand-up stretch and hydrate how dare you fine love you stony love you too
fine you got me i'm standing up i'm stretching
you can tell i'm standing up because my heart is hell of it hydrate
are we all stretching 135 from standing up yeah higher heart we stand
up being chased by the creepers
even strongy's cheeks clap a succubus every time strongy's cheeks claps a succubus gets their
wings that's hilarious wait i've not i've got my wee hoodie thing on foot in the way but
how many succubus would we just create enough regent is strong he gives you wings
it's doing you love it when a ship saves you from a planet
sit back down because i get knocked down
the moon oh we've got a countdown it's starting 60 oh what's gonna happen 55
mommy i swear to resist your tyranny over the reeflings the nile lings rise up
oh you've been waiting so long for this take a look slightly too whoa
oh
oh no it's gonna shit it
oh no where
oh no
it's gonna shit it
uh
no man i don't know how you held out down there we brought an atmosphere and we're descending
towards the landing site is that a building down there what do you mean you can't identify it
um hold on don't turn back now positions everyone touching down oh nine eight
it's coming from the building change course set thrusters before
oh no
oh
um
so did we technically cause this there
yeah
huh
um
is the siri gonna come see something funny or
come back into
this is how we go into the situation yeah
yeah
you caused it by not dying in the crash
you're out there
gotta find a way to shut down the gun i'm infected they've only like is that anglerfish strand in
itself right
slight problem i need myself like i need to heal up but i have nothing that can heal me up out here
maybe behemoth can get us going
maybe if i wasn't infected yeah but i don't infect myself
captain
what is over here
oh fuck i can only go 200 mirrors
you don't know like singers
you look a lot different
um
mommy the reefer the reefer's not gonna come over here i'm on island
thank you carnival for the tip you never you're a quiet one excuse me sorry pardon me coming through
oh no i'm saying no to a tablet
is this bait i feel like it's all bait
is the behemoth supposed to fit in the
go deeper trust me it's a fun time
oh who's that noti
i'm just a dark one
excuse me sorry
i can only go 200 meters i can't go inside can i go into the structure that's above me
oh no i like that like this that is so disorientating when you do that please don't do that again
what was that squid that attacked me
where internet went right where the good parts sorry
where was that thing that attacked me right i'm guessing i can't interact with these cubes
it's it's it's it's from the it's an alien fish
what was that
what ends up and where did he go
i just have to sit here and act like that's fine
i'm gonna get fucking charred by this thing
it's a mage reef
they detect an attack infected in people oh yeah oh yeah piss
oh that thing's coming for me all right well
oh i guess we're going to the
what's it mean
what does it mean i seem to i need to activate like a portal or something
yeah
Reaper roar hardly even more i can see something there it looks like a stinger
am i staring at a reaper is that him did you see that too or the pixels too much
i seem i can just go up and then we pull it go closer
oh here he is yeah that's him that's him all right
i don't know what you're supposed to do against him well i'm gonna hit my head on this block
do not say first what is there something past him
um
i have purple tablets so
how did i go did i take this back to the little thing for upgrades
i'm framing speed you'll eventually get better vehicles can deal with them
so go back to spawn and upgrade this
use the alien facility list as your gate
um
so upgrade you have to find the docking room you don't want to dock with me at the first
also your radio and aura house and stuff rest well sleepy head rest low to me to go to sleep
please don't worry i'm stumbling through this game right now i really am enjoying it but
docking bad isn't that when you put two tentacles together wait what's docking
what is docking i thought you made like two tentacles
oh the act of docking is when one reefling stretches the boar skin of his tentacle around
another tentacle i mean you have two tentacles technically you can do self docking so
yes with one being put inside to give a little kiss
uh right what was the alien's clue alien artifact alien deal no not another one the terminal deal
no it had like addresses and stuff on it it told me like it was a billion miles away or something
no artifact no what
this is the worst thing i've ever overheard so
or advanced theories alien egg evidence suggests that substantial number if not all of the local
species produced through eggling eggs can be found different species like likely flavor biomes as the
nesting ground likely awaiting ideal conditions in which to hatch for the delivery of some
vital enzyme which will take place also it's impossible to calculate the species of the egg
from the here however maybe also to stimulate a hatching are you squiddin me right now are we
raising a fucking army watching first time playthroughs of somatic is always fun for me
don't be afraid to take your time with it thank you uh crazy jesse yeah
uh i'm just stumbling a bit here i'm a bit confuzzled on what to do i need to find a dock
right i know where that dog is i think what i need to do is i need to go back and upgrade my shiz first
and i'm gonna save and i want to go like around this way a bit like against the area could
and you're i'm just getting told what to do now and your alien data i can't have a swear
and ask it without like dancing around it alien data
clues what quotes and clues
alien detail quotes and clues
it hates me
quotes and clues
disease research facility 800 so yeah i can't do it and then the distress signal
okay so let's go back and upgrade our ship because i can't even make it past 200 depths
i'm not taking it personally i literally cannot get uh past 200 800 yeah 200 and if asking me to
do 800 so i don't think so all right let's just very carefully whenever are we over
i'm okay i'm okay
it's okay add my poet i'm super fast i am speed oh there he is
oh jenki spotted me um something's telling me the ai might have locked on to me just a wee feeling
just a fucking wee bastard of a feeling can i get out of here like now
now's not the time to be squeaking in my ear thank you um
is he got me oh my god i'm going to the green sea so i literally cannot see ship
i'm going to the green sea i can't see nothing
and what makes that noise
oh my gosh i hate the green sea they knew exactly what they were doing when they put this in
you're safe what do you hope so what is it when i'm like a meter away from it a kilometer away
from the pod that's when the thing please hug mommy you okay are you getting as nervous as me
i'm the one in the control seat yeah this game basically embodies they knew what they were doing
when they did this one was the last time he saved i'm gonna save an upgrade how happy am i to see
manatees johnny you will have to explore the ship and fix the engine to find i have to go into the
ship but isn't that not next to uh a reaper you know you know that thing that i'm trying to avoid
isn't that all one of those
where'd i even climb on from the engine
everyone don't get in the way it's just it's not gonna work if you
get out right okay out sorry right at the end is when i crash lovely
um right upgrades i would totally do it from here right upgrades nope that's how you spawn them in
okay uh
from from this
god i have so much of these cubes i don't even know what to do with them
hmm repair laser no the crate or two habitat build up here
uh
your next step is finding moon bay fragments you need a moon pool
need a moon pool a moon pool what is the mean
the multipurpose room don't get too excited
Oh, I forgot to do my revende mission. Oh, we can get a double bed in. A moon pool.
You know Fab, a modification station as well. Need data boxes from lipods, right, you can
see basically. Make another locker and store that shite. You need to find it! Oh no! Oh,
sorry, I didn't do that. I need to find it. You never said something so mean to me before.
Uh, right, I need to make a locker. Hardly even, nor. Oh my god, that's the music scene.
Uh, right, locker. Um, I don't think we can start to open it. Put all the really important
shit in here. Diamonds, lithium, yeah, a fuck. I'm already out. What's making that noise? Oh,
that weird thing up there. Um, another locker? Oh, I need titanium. Of course I need titanium,
because why wouldn't I? Titanium in here? Oh, that would be too advantageous.
You need to scan other bases. That one? It's 300 meters down. I can't even reach that.
Was there a radio signal to give me my next lead? Because I think I'm needing it.
Okay, here we go. Where's my next lead?
Roger, Roger.
Um, can we do the 250?
Roger, Roger. Can we do that 250? Or will that not work? Compute. Creatures egg.
I didn't really know what to do with the creature's egg. I even need it. Just grabbed it.
Yeah, 250 is doable. Just park it at 200 and quickly go down. Okay, right. I'm going to keep the
tablets on me and then the ions can just be chill out here. Doesn't there is something that required
one of an ion? I can't remember. There was something that asked me for that ion. Oh, a purple tablet?
Hmm, why not just fucking construct them like that and call it a day?
There's a hatch in a tank.
Put the tablets in the semit to save space. The semit can carry stuff.
Hello, can you carry stuff? Wait, hold on. Let me repair you real quick.
Uh, this one?
On the side of it. Enter. Access. Upgrades. Oh. Oh. No, it's not quite what I was on.
Uh, I miss it. It has storage by default. Oh, you need a storage model? Ah, um, that's okay.
Uh, I don't actually know how to do that problem though.
Let's check. I'm not sure how to do it.
Honestly, not bad though. All things considered, this could have gone horribly wrong.
She's already got the vehicle mode, but she needs the mental. Okay.
Right, we're going to follow that leads, which was this one.
Uh, sus is fuck. Look how far away it is. I'm so going past the reaper to get there. Are you serious?
Yeah.
There. Oh, fuck sake. We're so gone past the reaper.
I'm like, I've saved. That's the main thing. I've saved. That is the main thing.
That's the main thing I've seen.
Um, you just need to run them five heads. Lower the audio. Well, there's your warning.
Okay, my wheels are here, so I'm safe.
Wheels are here, so it's safe.
Okay.
I'm sure this isn't going to go bad at all. Oh, wait, what?
Fuck.
Strip out of the roof back real.
Okay. Okay. Not bad. Not bad. I like these guys. They don't attack.
The only nice thing left in the ocean, jelly reeds.
Why am I being tense? I'm not even playing.
Whoa. Whoa.
What's what? You're scaring me. You're scaring me.
What?
Sorry, the whole sparked and I just saw that and I put two and two together and it was wrong, but
Yeah, yeah, knock off knock off.
Okay, am I safe to even go down?
Is there anything there? Am I okay? Fuck, is that sharp?
Oh, that's fine.
That's okay. That's okay.
That's fine. That's fine.
Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Don't
relax. Do you think there's a new entry? Right. What was the
though? Detecting volcanic activity and several unusual electromagnetic signatures in the region.
Yeah, him. Caution the one diving deeper. Yeah.
New details.
I've got to go. Oh, don't worry about having to go. Thank you very much for hanging. That goes for anyone
who's lurking if you need to fall asleep. You're welcome to sleep. Relax. No flake. It's called deep sleeping.
Uh, for a survivor, I miss one.
I'm not really a doctor. I know that's what my ID says, but I never have been. Okay.
These days need to know about manually resetting bones. When was the last time a top surgeon actually
cut someone open? Oh, that's what the robots are for. Doctors these days, we diagnoses
You know what he sounds like? In New York City.
But what is it that I'm not connected to the main network?
I'm bleeding. I got glowing green pustules growing on my hands. I run a self scan and it tells me I got skin irritation.
The only thing I studied in medical school was how to lie convincingly.
What the hell do I know about how to treat an alien disease?
What do I know about trying to treat an alien?
Okay. It's okay. I'm going to press escape. I'm going to press tab. I'm going to hold on spacebar.
I don't know what's got me. Something has got me. What are you? Fuck off, bitch.
Decompressed ass, get out of here.
Okay, it's okay. It was a small boo boo. Okay, we can't make it to the lifeline. We got a new radio
signal, so we have new help. Oh, that's so bright. It's a bone shark. I'll show you a bone.
Far, far. Okay, let's get back to the lifeboards.
Can we mark lifeboard 13 to get my foot up?
Habitat equipment for our vehicles. That wasn't that thing.
I'm going to be the other way around.
My wheels are back. I'm safe.
You could also check for other items. Where is the wheel shark? Oh, hi, baby. My little reef back.
Wait a minute, that's not my lifeboard. Wait, no, it is.
Is it? What? Well, him with a little 360.
You should speak to them like, oh boy. I just got here. Strone Encounter, something big. Yeah, the reaper.
If you, here, how about I do your favor?
I'm going to link a clip that a reefman has sent me of me screaming.
You will be warned that I'm screaming.
But here, if you miss, if you miss the scary part.
There, how about that?
Is that going to work? Did it work?
Yeah, I don't think I can. It doesn't look textured to click.
I like how I managed to squeeze out a bliet. I'm really impressed with myself.
Is that already clicked? Oh, no, I'm going to have to send it to an editor and stuff.
Oh, bliet. But yeah, that's the part you're wanting. Let me pin it.
Pin message, there you go.
Mommy screams are a part of the experience.
Hello, reef back. We love you. You're so cute.
I might need to deal with this power cell thingy, my bobber.
Wait, why are we going back already for? Oh, to pick up the next radio broadcast,
to get the next one that'll teach me how to get the parts to the moon thingy, my bobber.
Leave one for the tentacle, I think.
Oh, I don't know if anyone clipped the other one of Screamda.
Is that the alien facility of Screamda?
Hmm. Reef backs are powered up reeflings. We have three tentacles instead of two.
Yeah, these guys don't seem that scary anymore. Like, not even a little bit.
Let's not bump it this time. I'll just heal it up.
And then I've already thrown, read the radio and then it'll tell me where to go next.
Sorry. Oh, I knew just since, pardon me.
Hunting. Analyzing. Sharing subject locations with other agents.
Can you not?
Can you not? Does he come after me now?
There's definitely some banshee blood in the sand here.
Did he come after me now? Yes, no, maybe. Yes.
A tamer begins? Sort of? A tamer for what? They're gonna blow up my little base?
Can I like, snipe them from here with my little laser beam?
I don't know, probably. I don't know where to go from here.
You guys said I need to discover a moon base. Is it northeast, southwest?
When they see you, they'll be super hostile. Oh, I already got shanked in the alien facility,
didn't you? Worry about me. Can you repeat the question? Pod 13 is Moonpool? How? It's 300 meters.
I have to risk it for a biscuit? Why the fuck do I have this egg in here still?
Take it rid of this egg, please.
I might like to restart the fucking biome of the country and the country of the thing
and it's like, you have to do. All right, where's Mihima? All right, come on, let's go.
Come on, you've got some diamonds. Welcome aboard. All right, I'm off.
Left hold is 13.
Left hold is, oh, 13.
Hmm. I don't think I have the coordinates for 13. Only 19.
Mommy's having a headache. You can build a modification station.
I suppose I'll see what that does.
I've missed so much. No, you've not. It took me four hours to get here, I assure you.
Welcome aboard. All right, what do I need to, what do I need to build the modification station?
Lead diamond titanium computer chip. Lead titanium computer chip. And I forgot another thing.
Lead titanium computer chip.
Lead titanium. That's our site. That's our computer chip. What's our computer?
Gold and copper wire. Gold? I assume gold is what meets the copper wire, right?
Oh, sorry, copper wire.
Oh, copper ore. Oh.
Gold meets copper wire. Look, I wasn't thinking when I said that I would load.
Right, I need titanium, which is here. I might, unironically, have to go get some metal because
I've not been going for any.
Keep something coming after me.
Where's the metal? There was like, it's always when I go and find it, it's like, no.
What do you mean, no? Right, that's enough titanium. Then I need copper. I can do that.
Coral shell plate. Is that that thing? I need to stab it. Hold on, let me stab it.
When in doubt, stab it. Stop, I keep doing that one by accident.
Shadow scared me.
Oh.
Lead. Is that one good? Copper, I need another one.
It's terrible, I'm like so fucked up from the other one that nothing scares me in here. I'm like,
yeah, I don't care. Okay, that'll call for a little limb.
Oh, this must have been where I dropped other ones for me to go. Okay.
I'm like, mummy, I'm not afraid anymore.
Oh, no, that happened when she knew that there's bigger fish around.
Hmm, resilient mummy. I'm here to finish the mission, to escape this planet.
Okay, well, I can make it from the salvage, so it's not a problem.
Okay, I need copper water.
I need table coral, table coral. Table coral. Coral that is for a table. Whoa!
Obliac! What is that? Is this just a cutscene? I feel like this is just a cutscene.
Human! Hi.
Is this plot? Am I getting real plot? Is she coming to help me, friendly?
Okay, I'm gonna hit a computer chip.
What does that do? Spell scan power. Nope, I need the crafty one.
Okay. Boss machines.
Diamond. We got a diamond. We'll have a diamond. We'll go find a diamond.
We'll go find a diamond. Please tell me I've got a diamond in here. Nope. Oh, thank god.
Hmm.
I think we're great.
I think you know what, we'll use some more of the pollution station.
Oh, wow. Really? Thermal? Cooks and sterilizes small organisms for immediate consumption. Oh.
Oh, we have lithium.
Um.
Right. I'll take that. So I need four lithium and I need to make a high tank.
Fins, silicon, lithium as well. Everyone's lithium. You all love lithium out there?
Are you lithium? One, two, three, four. Gorgeous. Get in my inventory. Then what?
High capacity O2 tank. Oh, I'm not sure about that. Mechani.
I'm gonna make one of these in here because it's gonna annoy me going back and forth
constantly into the old one. Um, where is it?
There we go. Alright, I'm gonna go back in this pod and we're gonna make this like the main base
thing with all my supplies and stuff because I don't want to be constantly going back and forth
to that other one. Go titanium and that's like super common anyway.
Mommy, you have it? Oh, it's on my back. This? Oh, take it off.
More like this. Oh, that's so smart. Okay, let's go. Upgrade people. Upgrade.
What's my new oxygen? It's 225.
Okay, and then fence. I need two silicon rubber and one lithium.
Okay, two silicon. I think that's the seed.
Did you get nom'd yet? No, but the fish are after me. Right, silicon. I need two creepers.
Stop! That's really bad brain oil. But can I get more walkers though? Yeah, I would like a
shit ton more walkers. I'm not even kidding. I want like this place to be pent out.
So then I don't have to like keep fucking going back and forth everywhere.
Name the loafers?
I named them.
Like name them?
I'll put you in your locker. So this is you. This is an inkling that allows you and then
Denialing going here. What if you named one? I barely know it. Locker? I barely know it.
It's evil. Pick a locker. Any locker is here. Naming them is easier. Oh, name them as in like
metals are in here. Oh, I genuinely thought you meant like... Oh, that made... Okay.
Upon reflection, what you said now makes a lot more sense. I was like, sure, I can name them.
Like, I'll call them like Samantha or, you know, Daenerys or something like that. LaMau, Zola.
Oh, we got four.
I'm just going to take all this shit.
How deep is that?
Dammit. Damage secondary systems? Oops, did I never repair this?
Wait, did I never... Or did it just get like old over time? Am I dumb?
Have I been running this? No, no, no, no, no. I did that. I did that the first time.
Okay, I'm going to put all this shit in the other one.
And then I can't complete it. It just kind of takes a little bit of damage over time. Okay,
that's fine, friend. We are doing... What is that one?
Shove all this shit out. I'm not taking the purple tablets with me? Or am I taking the purple
tablets with me? Just take one tablet.
And then I need... How do I make that silicon thing again? I already forgot.
Forgive me, I'm small brain.
I just need two yellow things. Yeah, I can do that.
And then I've got the next upgrade.
I guess one tablet means you have access to everything else afterwards as well.
Oh, wait, was it stabbing it? I don't know. I can't remember. Let's go.
Trust me, you want to explore or you're a barrier-ish.
Are you a sea jelly? I'm a calm thing.
Mm-hmm.
Yes. Sorry, my brain's starting to lag.
Silicon rubber.
Silicon rubber. Right.
And then take off my fin.
And then come here and ultra-fin. Fuck yeah. Ultra cool fin. So now I'm moving faster.
Cyclops? Well, I don't know that. I don't even have the first module kit, whatever that is.
What? An ammo glass? Magnetate?
Uh, I in fact, I will upgrade the knife while we're at it, so why not?
So now what do you look like?
Oh, it's like steaming on the war? Interesting creative choices.
I guess I'll just shove this in here.
Not my problem, if it's not a membrane 2.
All right, leave all this because it's fine. I've got one purple and everything else is fine to receive.
And then we're going to go to the 300 meter life pod because that's our only clue.
It's steaming quickly.
Right. Where are we heading off to? Is there a reason I turned around?
Oh, I couldn't make it, I don't think. Because I need the moon.
Mummy is going to put stuff inside of us. It's absolutely steaming, it's wasted.
Uh, what do, um, you've got more air now. I think we'll manage.
Wait, why is that? I don't want to make you any more. How do I get rid of this?
Is it just going to be there?
More air, let's see. Then just go back into that fucking table.
Okay, with more air, I think we'll be okay.
All right, right. So, tell me, thank you.
Yes, I went back just, I'm sure there was an easier way to do it. I'm sure there was an easier way,
but small brain. Tee hee. Tee hee, thank you for understanding. Tee hee. I was born this way, Tee.
Aurora, can I make it to Aurora? More air plus rebreather? What's that?
Wait, I've got more? Wait, was there something I could upgrade there?
You run past the reaper you can get on the ship.
Yeah, I trust you. Okay, fine, fine, fine, fine, fine.
Where's Jack in? Right, we've got the high capacity tank.
Pronsuit depth module? Fucking science.
As the only streamer VTuber who made the connection of cave cell for making caves,
deny your small brain. Save first, right? We're going to save here and we're going to go to the
Aurora. Right, where's Aurora?
It's gently surfaced, where is she?
Now, before I be lying at past the reaper, how do I get on board? Is it the first engine?
Like, you know how one, two, three, four and four is like broken in the water? Is that how I get in?
Okay, the left side, front of the ship is how I get inside. Okay, say no more.
It's blown open at the front. Okay, not the only thing that's getting blown tonight with
how much you're carrying me through this game. Thank you, thank you.
Okay, let's make it, let's make it.
Now, there is a reaper kind of like, as if I'm running over fish when I'm skimming the water.
Go down.
She's not saving. I did. There, boom, save. Proof.
Right, front of the ship, front of the ship.
Part of the ship, part of the crew. I'm not going to go too deep because that's when the thingy
starts.
Find the nearest hole in the ship. Got ya.
Okay, so my wheels are here. That's fine.
Maybe a nice song could relax. Go down. No, I'm staying up on top.
I still seem to be in the whale's range, which is safe.
Okay, those are the resharky guys on the water.
Males scraps. Not much surviving around these parts.
And there's a depth there. Ooh.
Okay, okay.
Oh, so if I was in a dum-dum, I probably could have, like,
forgotten to the ship before it.
Left by the wheels. In this region, our sparse. The Aurora's radioactive fallout
will have devastating effects on the alien ecosystem if not contained within the next 24 hours.
Is this room supposed to go?
Like, am I supposed to get out now? No. I don't see the entrance.
Oh, that sounded fucking like it to me.
Len. Oh, come on. Give a break.
Give a break. No, I'm coming.
Yeah, that better hurt. I hope it burns. Had enough of you affecting me.
Enough. I hear you.
Right, where's the other guy? There's one more.
Well, there was another guy around here, but
I can't get over here. I've got a knife with your name on it. Come here.
There you go. Let's scan you. Scan? Scan? Scan? Okay, this is not where I'm supposed to go.
Oh.
And why is the music like this? There is another entrance.
Can you scan the dead bodies? Have you seen the bodies? I think I already did it on the other end.
Yeah. Of course, I get a radio signal now. You just can't do this.
There should be a path that goes a little higher, like back here or go around.
A little flip-flops. No, this is the dead end. Okay. Upstairs.
Where's my bohina?
You have to put out the fires with the extinguisher. Are we real?
That's too much of a fire to go through.
All right, that's definitely not it. So you're having me on this, maybe?
This maybe.
Warning. Ship's Structural Integrity is low.
Yeah, I'm going to ask the question. Equipment and laser cutters may be required.
Exploration is conducted at your own risk.
There's fucking so many. I'm going to get a rest. And how don't they burn in the fire?
I'm getting, they're jumping me. I'm getting gang violence. Jesus.
I'm T9. I made a kit. Thanks for telling me this.
Okay, game. Thank you for not registering the distance. No, I appreciate it.
Right, at least they're dying in two shots now instead of one.
Nah, I'm not having you jump me. Kiss off.
We'll be running out with one HP and then this will be the, oh, that one's infected.
He's super aggressive because we're kind of faked to be in. He's super aggressive.
Nah, I'm not having you jump me. Look at how many there is. Can you calm down, please?
Caution. Scans show the digestive trance of nearby life forms contain human tissues.
This time, I'm not surprised about that.
Oh my God.
Yeah, that's right. I showed you. I kicked him off the freaking, I kicked him off the ship.
Is this, is this anything?
What?
I did nothing. That can't be it.
Not that fire.
Oh, like this.
I wonder how painful it is to watch when you know where to, I'm supposed to be going right now.
That did nothing. Literally put the fire out. Oh, did it? Wait, I can go back there. Am I supposed
to go up? Look for the bridge at the ledge.
This?
Look for the bridge at the ledge.
Oh, there's a lake here, which makes me think it's here.
Look, flood lake.
Um, this? Yeah, no, it looks like this. Is that slanted or is it straight?
Okay, I can't seem to go that way, so it's not.
Yes, to the left of this, down here.
Your mummy isn't very smart.
It's not bad. It doesn't look like it's not.
You're almost there. You're cheering me on, but you're cheering on the wrong person.
This is terrible.
Look at me bastard. Leave me alone. I'm already failing the fucking exploration section. Please,
don't make me die to you guys.
There's a bridge at the top. It's not over here.
Fucking real.
I'm literally having a stroke. Where you scan the lamp is where the bridge starts.
Okay, so I'm going back to the lamp.
I love me a good lamp. I don't know about you. Love me a good lamp.
See that? I've had enough of that.
Okay, I am now back at the lamp. I am going to
save because the likelihood of me falling off the map right now is humongous.
I was supposed to just discover that myself, right? That's what I thought.
No, no. That's what I thought. That's what I thought, man.
First aid. Yeah, I'm going to need this one.
I'm going down.
At least let me see.
Sorry.
Integrate new PDA data.
Would you be any of them?
And what was that? Compulsion cannon? What's the PDA data?
I wish they would make it a bit obvious what I just picked up there.
No.
I'm looting.
If I could see, I'm looting.
Can I go up here?
It's in the voice notes.
Is that one available?
Voice log? It's not. It's just a last thing.
Aurora engineering drone.
Voice recognition.
Engineer Barclay and Chief Technology Officer, you identified.
Drone, give me a propulsion cannon.
Repulsion cannon retrieved.
Hey, Berkeley, install that circuit box with that repulsion cannon
and you'll punch a hole in the cargo bay.
Damn it, drone. I said propulsion, not repulsion. Recalibrate sensors.
Sensors recalibrated.
Sensors aren't the problem. I tweaked the program.
It's like you now, as other light being told what to do.
Drone, I know.
His name's Albert now.
Albert, I know it's not your fault, but it would really help me do my job
if you'd bring me what I asked for. Thanks for your time.
Propulsion cannon retrieved.
Thank you. Now go away.
Endring.
Hibernation mode.
Boss, this hobby of yours isn't making my job any easier. Or safer.
Maybe so, but it's all the integrating new PDA data.
Next spacewalk in my skivvy.
Integrating new PDA data. Integrating new PDA data.
New reprint.
Did no one have some design thinking about this at all?
Lake.
Lake. So is that everything I needed from here?
Can you scan the data? Like the terminal?
There's a guy in the chair.
Oh, it's not.
You can jump through the boxes below.
Take the poster.
What?
That can pin for my wee lab?
So I can go down here?
Is that everything?
You can decorate your home.
You can pimp out the double bed.
Actually, yeah, I should do that.
We'll make the double bed and then we'll call it there.
And we'll come back to this.
We need a mummy.
Wait, did you say I could go this way?
Or did I misunderstand your message?
I don't know.
What?
Crouch?
Is crouch not?
There's not even a crouch in this game.
C, control, shift, catwalk, path.
This game doesn't have crouch in it.
Surely we are being trolled.
Oh, they're actually using a crouch.
I need a proportion cannon.
Want to go further in here?
Am I done?
Yeah, you can jump over it.
Don't be afraid to jump, bro.
No, I ran out of stamina right at the end.
The company took her knees.
Clearly.
I'm like fucking bouncing off of this.
Is this where I'm supposed to go next?
The compulsion thing moves boxes around?
Let's re-fan down whoever fucking coded this bit.
Oh, all right.
I have one complaint.
Am I allowed to say it?
I don't want to say it.
Although it actually might just be the way I play the game.
Maybe I shouldn't say it.
Whenever I feel like I'm finally getting something
instantly blocked off.
It's not even like a little bit of exploration at the
moment.
If I have that builder, what's going to build the fucking
tool?
So I have to go all the way back then?
I have to go all the way back to make this gun
just to progress when I'm already at the fucking ship?
They couldn't have like been nice and
just been like, oh, here's a station for you.
So you don't have to go all the way back.
Your brain will lose brain cells because there's no fast travel.
Oh, they give you a full fire extinguisher?
I didn't know that.
Oh, I was going to say that.
What happens if you showed up when you fire extinguish one?
Mommy, you can build anywhere.
How?
I've no got the compulsion, Rachel.
Why is it jiggling?
It's twerking.
Relax.
Oh, yeah.
Go and fuck off.
Honestly.
Oh.
A compulsion, Rachel.
Stop.
Right.
Repulsion cannon?
I don't have anything to do with that.
Inhabitat builder.
Oh my gosh, it's twerking.
Are you mean the actual tool habitat builder?
Can you do that thing where you tell me what to do,
and then do the arrow, and then do the next thing?
Without the compulsion cannon, you can free the door downstairs?
Yes.
My dear refling, but I don't know what or how to access this.
You can build the crafter.
So making it twerk.
Oh my god.
It wants me to make a...
Why don't they just provide the fucking item?
Like, not to be controversial, but...
Like, I'm sorry to get political, but why?
Why make me come all this way, literally all this way,
only to feel like, right, go back.
You've not got this item.
You need one more scam before you can even build the cannon anyway.
Exactly.
Like, I'm just glad I made it alive.
Or go back to base real quick.
Yes, I'll be a jiffy.
And then by the time I get back to base,
I actually need to put a battery and a moe-ing thing in my boba.
Will wiki the other PC?
I'll tell you what, I'll go back to base.
I'll make the double bed and hang the poster up.
We'll have Balmchika Wampwamp time.
And then we'll come back another day.
Jump off the ledge.
Although that would have been faster.
Yes, you're correct.
Cause, uh...
The...
I lanterns again, but I don't think that's why they did it this way.
It just feels a bit like,
could have thrown me a bow and like,
oh it's worth.
Like...
And he's right there.
He's ready to fucking snake me.
I'm fucking revert.
I'm twerking out here.
Put my eyes on him.
I'm bobbling up and down that water.
Right, I don't think he's gonna bother me, mum.
You put six in there.
Hours in, I earned a Balmchika Wampwamp.
What's going on?
Just the cute guys that don't effect,
which I like.
They're my favorite kind.
I don't remember, I don't remember,
but that's why I'm so foolish.
Cause, baby, tonight...
Oh.
Is that a new resource?
100 meters.
Oxygen efficiency decreased.
That's not anything.
Nope.
I'm seeing the fuck out of this tree.
Fuck it.
I'm in.
Okay.
Before I beat the game, I forgot one single resources
that I needed for the ending
that you could only get at the furthest point.
And the game had to circle the entire map route.
I'd believe it.
I would believe that.
And I can see myself doing that.
To be only.
Scan it.
Oh.
That makes a lot more sense now that you've set it.
500 meters.
So we're safe.
There's no Leviathan's or anything like that.
Let's not worry about that just yet.
I mean, I feel like I've hardly even got into the game.
To be on it, not to be career introvertial.
I feel like I've only just started.
Oh, those fish didn't get ran over.
Yeah.
I'm on 41 battery from a wee thingy mob over as well.
And I'm a bit late.
The last blueprint you need for the repulsion is in light port 12.
Hmm.
Well, we'll see if I've been given a message from light port 12 or not.
Would they be so kind?
This is Ulterra HQ.
This may be your only communications window.
We can't send a rescue ship all the way out there.
So Aurora, you're just going to have to meet us
halfway.
We've uploaded blueprints to the ship's computer.
What is the sandwich run?
You in?
Yeah.
Give me a second.
Why am I not in the high security terminal
in the captain's quarters?
It's still functional.
Becky's leaving in like five minutes.
All right.
Tell Becky I'll just take the regular.
Yeah.
She'll know what I mean.
The code should be.
She doesn't?
Just tell her the regular, dude.
OK.
The code.
I'll say regular.
She's like, what's the regular?
I'm going to give you the code.
Give us the code.
82679.
The regular is just a ham and cheese.
OK.
Would you just say ham and cheese?
Ham and cheese.
OK.
No, but he's actually got such a point, though.
Don't say the regular.
If someone's doing your favor, don't say the regular.
No.
Say what you want.
Get your whole bussy.
That guy's winding strong enough.
Give us the code.
Right.
Compulsion can.
Oh, whole meal states.
Right.
That's it.
We're shagging.
Get me in here.
Right.
How?
I need to make a bit.
Welcome to the board, captain.
Yes.
Welcome.
I do feel welcome.
Thank you.
Um, where is our bed?
What I need to make that?
Titanium and fiber mesh.
I don't have fiber mesh.
How do you make fiber mesh?
Fiber mesh?
Oh, seaweed.
Of course.
I knew that.
Have I got titanium and seaweed?
Wrong thing.
Nope.
Seaweed.
Yoy.
And then
I really not got titanium in here.
I'm going to.
I do not prefer to have titanium.
And that's okay.
I am not going to take it personally.
That I don't have titanium.
It does not impede my gameplay that much.
Relax.
Breathe in.
Breathe out.
You have three in the middle one.
That off.
I believe that.
I'll give a little kiss.
It looks like a little disco ball, honestly.
But I feel like I can be on the water for so long now.
Look at how much oxygen I have.
I can breathe.
Well, underwater.
Like literally, I feel like I have so much now.
Radiation detectives.
Good thing I'm going straight back down.
It's like a disco ball.
It does.
Well, having a little party on the back of its tail.
It's ready to party.
Okay, let's make this bed.
Let's hang up the poster.
Let's put copyright free saxophone music on.
Let's get in there.
Hello.
Thank you.
And then bed.
No, bed.
Bed is this one.
Bed.
Oh, fiber mesh.
Sorry.
I need two strands of fucking kelp.
I need two big strands of kelp
to get one.
We hang like that, all right.
No, I'm not playing with food and more.
I would have reached quite long ago.
Right.
So when you enter, okay.
When you enter.
Wait, where's the door?
Ah, close enough.
Close enough.
When you enter, there's our bed.
And then we need to hang the poster up.
Bed.
Bind it?
Like the binding of items.
And then boom.
Oh my God.
So when you enter, it's just like, come on in.
You know what you want.
You can sleep now.
Come on, let's go bed together.
The poster gets you excited.
Oh, yes.
It really wakes you up.
There.
And then we wake up well rested
after having our basic double bed shenanigan.
The binding of Isaac, the hit video game
loved by these, Veronica.
Mommy, I'm not allowed to ink.
This is evil.
Oh, what's wrong?
Are you thinking about inking?
Is it on your main?
Right.
Ah, I'm satisfied to wrap it up.
If you're satisfied to wrap it up.
Yes.
May wrap up, but you don't need a wrapper.
Then mommy can sweep.
Yes.
Ah, right.
I'm going to save there.
I'll read some marshmallows
and then we'll redirect into Azura.
And if she's coming up.
I think Azura would be the next one coming up.
Uh, I think, uh, my followers.
I don't, am I?
Does she be following?
No.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, she's right in your fucking gun case.
Oh, that's funny.
That's funny.
She's, she's right in your, I mean,
your bedrooms, your bedrooms.
She's right in your bedrooms.
My apologies.
I was misquoted.
Azura is like, okay, we'll redirect into Azura.
I will read some marshmallows.
Uh, just, if it's missed anything.
Mommy can't stop thinking about my tentacle.
Missanjimiko Streamart and Health.
Wow.
Would I be so mean to like purposefully do that?
No, I couldn't be.
Couldn't, I couldn't be that evil.
I'm not mean.
I'm nice.
Okay.
Really nice.
Hi, strongy.
Shame.
Wait, no, what?
Hi, mommy.
Hi, Evelyn.
Shameless strongy merch plug.
Every market has a hoodie and sweatpants
feel going on right now that ends fair.
Oh, well, if you're ever in the mid for a hood.
Denialings and shambles, honestly.
Another clip, a bit of the Tizm.
Okay, hold on.
What's the clip?
There's one minute long.
Oh, it was named in the lockers.
Mummy president, a second plaintiff hit them.
Oh, Ruflin, Ruflin, that anniversary was really recent.
Ruflin, you made me read that out loud.
Please, please pause.
It's going to blow up.
Oh, fuck.
Like, wait, it blows up further.
It's not, I already blew up once.
It blew up like it's core.
I can't believe you made me say that.
I don't.
Strongy, have every intent of destroying me during this week
of denial.
I'm really going to be kind of sure.
I think the refunds are going to blow up.
Turn on the TV, strongy.
Any channel, fuck.
You're not American.
That's okay.
No, I never said it in the first place.
Now hold on a minute.
You can say the streams are prerecorded,
but you kind of say that I'm fucking putting that shit.
What is your sexuality?
I'm riefling sexual.
I'm rief sexual.
I need some R words.
R word and mumma.
All of that.
I'm rief sexual.
I like it.
Yes.
Mummy, I didn't get to play yesterday because of work.
Should I participate?
No, you didn't play.
That's okay.
No, not the reefs.
They're spoiled as it is.
Is it time for a daily group?
No.
She sees the reef when it needs to snuggle,
struggle them, literally.
I need to get artwork of me going feral.
Like as soon as a spot, like spot yet over.
It seems like everything's relatively calm and quiet
on the recent side.
Are you guys going to be okay if I redirect into a zero?
And then we'll continue this.
Got baby rabies?
I bring on the struggle snuggles.
Yeah, I think you can handle it.
That's cute.
Mumma, I have to go do some stuff.
Love you, love you too, reef.
Then have a good night.
You have a good night too.
No, great.
There are denials among us.
Me.
Yeah, you're going to enjoy as soon as soon as you can.
Cave reviews soon.
Thank you so much.
I feel like, oh, wait, hold on.
Hold on.
I don't think my shoes are done.
And my display is broken.
I don't know why display does this to me.
I feel like it is a personal attack on me.
Oh, I'm like, come on.
Okay, now I'm not going to go rip.
Um, next.
Oh God, can I even remember anything I picked next week?
Fuck.
I'm trying to think of one thing I picked for next week.
We're not doing the Left 4 Dead Streams night next week
because there's like, I think I did it wrong.
I'm so sorry.
I've completely forgotten what I planned next week.
An ASMR stream?
Okay, slay.
A membership stream?
What else did I pick?
Um, I've no got a fucking review.
Have a Austin power.
Oh, wait, I tell.
Hold on.
Pause the tunes.
I've just, I've just got it.
I've got it.
There is a hand cam stream next week.
Okay, hold on.
Is this going to work?
I don't know.
Hold on.
I got my schedule.
You ready for it?
Where is it?
Uh, it's not displayed.
What is going on?
My OBS is having a really hard time.
I'll like tell it to show something and then it doesn't.
And it's like, no, I'm not showing.
I'm like, what do you mean you're not showing?
What do you mean you're not going to show the file
that I have identified for you to fucking show?
She's never gone home.
Okay, so we're, so two hand cam streams.
Um, this two hand cam streams.
So we're opening Pokemon cards.
Tomorrow.
And then, um, Sheevie let me rope her into playing Portal 2
for the first time.
And then we're doing one hand of clapping.
Where's like, it's not me clapping without my hands.
Okay.
I promise that comes later.
Oh, my game's playing again.
Sorry.
And then I'm doing fable three.
I'm doing it over two parts.
And then I'm doing a 25 K celebration stream.
Which rhymes with Vengebus.
Um, and then I'm doing a hand cam stream,
which is clay foam hand cam.
I'm gonna, I've never done it in my life,
but I'm going to do it.
I'm going to give it a shot.
Okay.
I'm going to try and make everyone's mascots.
Obviously going to start with my refunds first.
Um, and then maybe let's like spin a wheel.
Um, and then we'll make everyone's mascots.
But yeah.
Um, there is a membership ASMR.
There's a membership script right in,
and then membership watch along.
So only three membership streams this week.
Bye.
Um, member 25 K continued.
Oh my days.
I won't be dumped by this.
So yeah.
Clealing's rise up.
Oh, and lay.
I mean, we bet.
Hold on.
I needed to.
That was very audible.
Bring on the awkward long handshakes.
Wait, what's an awkward long handshake?
Only three for eating, dude.
I'm almost happy I'm a specific stream.
Are you in Scotland?
No, I was born there though.
I'm going back there.
So I wrap up my business.
Only three.
Mommy, you do more membership things in a week
than what's done a month.
You said it.
Not me.
You were the one who said it,
but you were thinking it.
Or be playing.
You were thinking it.
And the good thing is when next week's finished,
we're going to be at a new part again.
I don't think that's a far.
Hmm.
I think it was a ship.
Has been a few days.
Um.
Then we'll be very shortly hitting the four months
streaming mark.
Can you believe it?
Oh, which is insane to think of it.
Like four freaking months together.
Hmm.
A what?
A shite?
A jobby?
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Were you expecting?
I need to go for an idle meeting.
Give me a moment.
No, around here.
We do big fat shites in that pan.
So get on that toilet and get fucking even.
I want you to push so hard that the fucking air that comes
out of your ass is enough to cut bricks.
Okay.
That's how hard I want you pushing on that toilet.
We do fucking shites around here.
We don't know.
We don't do idle meetings around these parts.
You what?
I just.
Anyway, yes, that's our agenda nation.
So I'll start putting up those streams, uh, those shortly.
Um, but yes, more hand cam.
Oh my god.
Surprise.
Yes, we're going.
I have, I bought a Pokemon set.
It is called, it's behind me.
It's called Paladin's fate.
No, Pal, Paladin's fate.
Oh my god, I'm such a fake Pokemon enjoyer.
Um, and then I also have the Pokedex.
So we can like slot it in the right coin thing.
Aim a bobber.
The risk is high that you see my face because of the reflective surfaces,
but you know, just imagine like a really depressed looking guy.
And then it's fine.
It's fine.
Don't use shite.
Uh, a Paladin's fate?
Is this Paladin's fate?
And it had a mimic key on the front.
So winner.
I had a stomach bug two weeks ago.
That's blessed and everything.
Gamba in real life.
Yes.
You're gonna keep talking Scottish accents.
Amazing.
I really depressed cute looking guy.
So yeah, that's the agenda nation for next week.
Sorry, uh, is there a stream state?
No, there isn't.
Oh, I must have had to make way for the stream site
for the 25k celebration.
Hmm, why is there no stream site?
I suppose with the stream site numbers after 11 days.
The cutest girl here.
I'm looking forward to next week.
Yeah.
And I'll try and rework Subnautica into the next week
and Left 4 Dead 2 into the week after
to get the thingy.
As always, the stream started the exact same time.
Things have calmed down now.
I don't really have to mix around stream times
for anything or collabs.
Probably collabs or the ASMR stream train
is kind of the only exception to my stream time.
So as I said, I'll be here every day at the same time.
I look forward to seeing cute little things Monday or Wednesday.
Um, what happened to the Overwatch board?
Um, I got a little bit too much.
Um, so I had to remove it for safety
because I got a little too in over my head.
Um, so I do apologize without, um, but I couldn't do that.
We will redirect into the lovely Azura Duley.
While she's reviewing your Yun KV,
um, please do enjoy her to your heart's content.
I will see you tomorrow.
And you get to look at my lovely nails again.
That's right.
And you get to see my nails again.
I'm actually really interested in more hand cam streams.
I have so much fun doing those.
Like, it feels like I can do so much more in them.
But yeah, I might do hand cam ASMRs once a month.
And then I'll get a new nail set just to feel extra feminine.
Oh, feminine, feminine, baby, baby, baby, baby, baby.
Okay, I love you lots, little v-flin.
How many kisses?
How many, oh god, how does kisses work in this game?
How many things did we get?
I don't, I don't know how to sign kisses.
We unlocked a lot of stuff.
225 kisses for oxygen, a zillion.
Will the nail color be another hint?
I'll see. It depends what happens.
Obama will be in Texas for today.
How many days have passed?
Oh, good one, good one.
We're on day 19.
Okay.
19, 19, 19, 19, 19, 19, 19, 19, 19, 19, 19.
for the extra. Please enjoy Azura and as always Azura isn't me and I am not
Azura so she likes things differently from the way I do when it comes to
communicating in chat but as always I know you will behave because you are my
friend. And I will see you tomorrow for some awesome Pokemon cards. You need to
wish me luck and you need to tell me how to open them. Do I put like two to the
back or something? We'll find out tomorrow okay? Love ya, see you tomorrow. Have a
good rest and have a good hydration and a good stretch okay? Bye bye and remember
no inking.